I like these five,
four,
three,
two.
Uno.
Yes.
Hey everybody.
I'm still out of breath.
Yeah.
Uh,
Brendan Schaub and Brian Callen were engaged in some shenanigans.
They rough house Sunday.
Rough House.
I was trying to chill.
I was talking,
I was poking the bear.
I got,
I had too much coffee and I went,
I went into,
I got into his face and then he decided to,
Jamie's chose me and I'll be on my Instagram story.
Double tap outs.
Yeah,
that was not right.
You had a tap.
Well I got a fucking huge a rug burn on my fucking forehead.
Now that that's it.
That kind of,
well that's what happens.
What,
what kind of Shit fucking production is this?
Look at this.
They got who's running?
The camera's over there in England.
They showed niner in the background.
The fucking,
the curtain that's covering the monitors.
Whoever did that sucks.
This is what happens.
And the UFC got rid of all the old guys.
Now you got new guys over there in England to or wherever the fuck home.
You know.
So Eddie Bravo can't be here folks cause he's on the other side of the world
where Flatworld that shit is ironic.
The flat,
the flat world.
Where is he right now?
Ticking necessarily says the earth is flat.
He's never necessarily set it.
He just says things like,
I don't know Bro.
Take a look at it.
When you look into it.
I'm not saying it's round.
I'm not saying it's flat.
What's amazing though is the angry flat earth people when even post something
like that.
Oh my God,
they get so mad.
But don't you think you're being trolled for the most part?
No.
Really.
I think people are that fucking stupid.
I think there's a bunch of meth babies out there.
I think there's a bunch of dummies who were eating nothing but sugar and they
had kids and these kids are stupid as fuck.
That's fair.
It might be true.
I think there's like a few trolling,
but in general the,
the math of those morons,
they believe,
well a lot of people just don't have any idea of any kind of tradition of where
we came to these conclusions.
So they think that history starting right now with them?
Well,
you know what I mean,
there's a lot of laziness is a lot and there's also a lot of confirmation bias.
They have these ideas in their head and they don't look into them.
They're just not interested in like,
uh,
really getting into it.
Well,
you know,
like listening to that,
that debate with Michael Shermer and Randall Carlson and Graham Hancock,
like if you as a scientist and smart people,
they're very careful about what they say because they get called out on it.
Sure.
You know what I mean?
And and arriving at real conclusions is something they tend to avoid.
They'll just have these big discussions and kind of approximate what probably
happened.
Yeah.
And even in that discussion,
you got to see people that got into trouble for saying something didn't happen.
And so then as Randall started unveiling more evidence and Graham started
unveiling more evidence,
it was one of those things where everybody kind of had it back up and go,
okay,
well you can't say it didn't happen because of all this stuff that we know did
happen now.
And so it's,
it's very complicated when you start saying you know things and when you know
almost nothing about science and space and astrophysics and all the different
shit that you need to know to understand satellites and ice walls.
Shit.
How about the way our mind works like that?
Tobolowsky what's his name?
Who I just listened to podcasts so I listened to a couple of his lectures back
in the day on,
on ted.com but like when he was talking about all the variables that lend
themselves to how your brain works and who you are and good luck getting to a
conclusion.
He says staunched determinism believe will not even though I shouldn't say a
believer because he's a scientist,
but what his conclusion,
I mean what he's trying to establish with people is that there's so many
variables that go into you being you biological,
very illogical variables,
genetic variables,
variables in terms of like what genes are turned on by stress when your mother's
has you in the womb.
Yeah.
There's so much shit that goes into you being a person.
And so,
you know what he's saying is that like when we look back on today and we look
back at people being punished for certain things that they did and be an
imprisoned,
we're going to think it's absolutely barbaric when when real neurologists firmly
established the actual science behind human behavior.
I mean meaning that we don't really have free will where w w our behavior is
dictated by our biology and our machine.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean there's gotta be some will because why else are they're inspirational
memes that strippers put on their Instagram page.
This has gotta be
shy to rise
above the try and,
and you can't get inspired,
right?
Yes.
Like we see this is where the freewill argument kind of hits a bump in the road
because you can get inspired by shit and when you do and get inspired by Shitty
can improve your life for how long though,
right?
Yeah.
Well it depends.
They both seem changes.
What's that old expression is that inspiration is like bathing.
It's effective,
but you need to do it daily.
Yeah.
Or how about the fact that punishment but got to read a little bit every now and
then.
Punish my doesn't know.
I mean that's some old school shit.
I just dropped my tattoo.
I'm getting that as a tattoo
on my dog.
That's a bold move guys.
Who Tattoo Their Dick
for a tab or would you like what would you do?
We should tell you to your Dick Black.
Just all black.
Just a black band.
Black people do that.
They get like their whole arm black.
That's a weird,
I wonder why I thought it was cause they messed up and then God better to cover
everything.
Go Black.
But no for some people they do do it for that and some people do it because they
just want their whole arm to be black.
Yeah.
Some people have bands can look good and then there are people that just get
random shit like a Cadillac or a doll.
Well how about Travis Barker?
He's got everything.
You name it,
he's got it.
It's all right.
Yeah,
I got that tactic just to doodle pad a tattoo.
The Cadillac tax.
He has a guy
is guy,
a things guys cartoon and I forget the guy's name,
but he'll have two of them worked on at the same time.
Jesus Christ both on his back just doing work dudes like that,
like run out of cannabis,
like he's kind of running out of canvas space.
I didn't know his whole head is done.
Jesus taught us this whole head is done but a lot.
I mean he's had a lot of those tattoos.
We remembered he got on that plane crash and he had like third degree burns all
over his body.
I remember he got a lot of them after that cover.
Kind of that bullshit.
Fucking crazy.
He's same man.
He survives that Guy Dj am and then the guy kills himself afterwards when he was
really fucked up right after on these drugs.
I use a little fine before then and then goes to the hospital and then you know
you're on the medication.
The neighborhood labs.
I know a woman who got injured like that and then she was,
they put her on morphine and she has to basically battle a morphine addiction
the rest of her life.
She said,
I will always be addicted to opiates.
I'll always want it.
Don't have to be,
but yeah.
Well No,
I'm saying she's got that urge all the time.
But you got that urge when you had your nose fixed,
right?
Yadda issue.
But what's it like a,
you just want them all the time.
Like what is it like when you say you want,
I'm like,
what's the feeling like?
Like the same feeling as like a,
I don't like if you crave something,
like you're constantly craving it.
And I got it.
I'm good right now.
I'd be so much better than Oxycontin,
you know?
Wow.
Like this.
Or We'd be going out like it's going to be fun.
It'd be so much fun if I said one oxycotton though.
Wow.
And they just start doing like,
and you're like,
damn,
I'm doing this for everything.
You were just oxy and up on the nonstop.
Wow.
And they're so easy to get Jesus Christ.
So no one ever questioned you when you wanted to get a refill or anything like
that?
No,
because the doctor was like,
Hey,
I'm hip,
I'm cool.
Here's like 300.
You know,
like a shitload.
He liked you cause you're a UFC guy.
Yeah we were boys.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Jesus Christ.
Did you ever tell him hey fuck face.
He kind of turned me into an addict.
No,
I kind of blame myself.
Yeah.
Well that's good.
That's healthy of you.
That was like smashing machine when they went to do that.
That a thing that Mark Kirk.
Oh yeah,
they didn't expect,
uh,
I know the guys who made it,
they didn't extend it and know it was going to take that turn.
Well they went to get him like right when the water went over the top like right
when he crested over the top.
That's the documentary I'm working on.
I've never seen.
It's really good.
Cause they went to,
they went to document the greatest fighter on earth cause car was this just
juice machine?
How long ago was this made shit man?
Early two thousands.
Yeah.
So mark,
mark and house on 88 it was actually,
I think it might've been because I remember you and I talking to him in 1997 and
he was to 60 he had just,
he just need that ranger in the face.
Rancher.
Stott.
Yup.
And then I said,
I said,
you wrestled at one 88.
He said,
yeah.
I said,
what are you wait nine to six.
He put a little miracle grow in my cereal every morning.
And I was like,
God damn his steroids.
Good on him.
Steroids.
They looked amazing on him.
He uh,
he's gay too or no?
Is that like you don't know?
Well,
I dunno.
I hope so.
I know.
It's a wonderful man.
A really nice man.
I hope he's gay.
What's going on here?
So who are these gentleman?
The guy with the writing on his arm or Hermann for 30 right now,
son Hermanson and Nicholson and the four 20 84274206425 in round one.
If you want to sync up,
you look at the fighters on this card and it's a fucking good luck with this
spelling,
but to get them back then Jesus Christ,
just those shelters dealt so big.
Oh my God.
And he'd made her American.
He'd wear American flag shorts.
That amazing.
Yeah,
he was,
oh yeah.
They called him the specimen,
right.
Will they fart?
They started out calling the specimen then they call it the started calling the
smashing machine when he fought,
I forget who he follows.
Damn globish Dan Boba.
She got Dan Bowbridge down and he submitted him by shoving his chin in his
eyeball that he'd put his chin in his eye socket and just grabbed the back of
his neck.
Blumkin forced his chin was eyeball head move of all time.
All time.
It's up there.
It's a great meeting.
She'll meet head movement and you need to do that kind of a move.
I mean I know it's a move for a shirt,
some meat hedge,
but it's a move beam.
Is it more of a meathead moved in the can opener cause he submitted a guy with a
can opener too.
I feel like they can't open a little more technical.
He Jackson Dude's neck with a candle.
But how has it more technical?
You just pull on a guy's head but you got to get them position.
I mean for you if you're just doing like fuck it.
Shinda I Chen the eyeballs.
No techniques like my more to that recall.
That's actually more tactical that a can opener or is it more barbaric?
It's more about Baird for sure,
but I mean I guess that would be,
well that's fights over I guess this Dude Jack Ma Hammered Jack in mine.
I guess the big issue with a 12 to six eyeballs would be if a guy was down and
you crush it right into the eyeball.
Yeah.
This is more like a steamroll approach,
which just real slow mush.
I don't,
it bothers me that I can't do that to a man.
What are we looking at up there,
Jim?
Oh sorry.
I thought we thought you're showing us something.
I'm going to work on that technique.
You couldn't do that to a man?
Is that what you're saying?
I mean,
you know,
I just kind of could a smaller guy and I'm fresh off my wound.
I,
my head still hurts from you.
You fucking hurting Josh Martin on the ground and stuck your Chin in his
eyeball.
I think you get some them.
There are guys that got them into this,
which was a comedian.
Oh yeah,
there are certain communities I can do that too.
Yeah.
I feel like it's all a pecking order,
isn't it?
To Jay Davis might give you a hard time.
Remember when,
uh,
Ballantine's uh,
over,
remember when he got the can opener on Ray Sefo.
You remember that?
Yeah.
Super old school.
Did he submit it with that?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
I'm pretty,
I'm pretty sure it was out of sight control.
Valentine Overeem submitted,
ran to go tour with [inaudible]
old school.
Old School.
Yeah.
He just didn't have it like the rain.
No.
Well,
he would fall apart when the,
when the bombs started dropping,
when the going got tough.
He was like,
you know what,
fuck this check please.
When you,
when you're,
when you're ready.
CFO who didn't,
he was more of a striker,
wasn't he?
Yeah,
to say the least.
So for him,
I guess getting caught in a can opener just as a function of just like,
you wouldn't get a high level Jujitsu and can opener,
would you?
Or would you?
There's no situation that's super gorilla.
Like Mark Kirk could get a good black belt in one if like,
he just could.
The guy just could not get out and exhausted.
And if mark gets a hold of your neck,
like he just can't rip your ligaments apart,
your tendons and ligaments.
Back then he was so gorilla strong.
I mean,
it didn't even make any sense.
Yeah.
He was so stupid.
Strong.
And you're not used to it.
Like if it caught you off guard,
like I had Brian,
uh,
a waterman,
Ron Waterman take literally take my face and smash it between his tits and I
have to tap out,
you know,
huge jazz shoes.
All Tan.
Literally took his tissue,
smashed my face,
cro cop fucked him up.
That was one of the soccer kicked him in the,
yeah,
that was one of the first like cro cop becoming cro cop fights when cro cop will
started learning take down defense motherfuckers got terrified.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
that Guy Shitty fucked in with my nose.
Do you know what's funny is when you see
it was so embarrassing and Shane goes,
Shane,
Carmen it,
it's just three of us in the room and chank Olga's dam
and I go,
have you ever tapped that?
Ego's
not like that.
You're looking for some kind of comradery and it was just dead silence and I was
just this pussy of the day.
Maybe come back next week.
Do you know what's funny is when a guys who've never had any combat experience,
especially with wrestling,
get caught up with a guy who has experienced so,
but dove had never had any wrestling and he grabbed onto may,
him Miller and Jason was kind of showing him,
just hit my,
you know,
it's like we're all on a wood floor.
And Jason started showing him just a couple of things where Doug was grabbing
him and stuff.
And dove was so kind of,
and he's boxed so he knows the difference with striking.
But he called me up the next day and he said it's very difficult for me to get
my head around this.
I said what he said to be that dominated by another man that easily,
and to realize that I could just be as dove,
have a mirror in his house.
He knows better,
he knows better,
but he's,
he's not a bad boxer for an actor or a comedian.
He knows better.
Yeah.
But there doing black belts,
she'll be honest about what's going on though,
have dumbbells punch in the face.
Dub is a good boxer.
Luck with that.
He spars a lot with dove.
Dove is not a bad box for a Mac man,
especially at this price,
especially at his prime.
May hand was a monster man was a bad mother fucker,
you know,
like I really feel like mayhem just took too much punishment and his career.
And I think,
you know,
he also had some,
some obvious deep mental health issues and demons.
Yeah.
He a rough,
rough upbringing.
I just think,
yeah,
I like my hand.
All those,
those weird things you can't control.
I think that all of that accumulated on him and then 100% brain trauma may be
100% brain trauma.
Man,
that Bisping fight was a motherfucker.
Dude.
Bisping beat the shit out of him before that though,
cause gambling,
that's really going into that fight like that wasn't,
I've never seen mayhem fight like that before he even took a punch.
I was like,
what the fuck is he doing?
Well,
that was a big fight for him because that was one of the first fights we had a
lot to lose because he was on the ultimate fighter coaching against Bisping and
the ultimate fighter.
He ain't had.
See if you could pull up Mark Carr submitting Dan Bovis where the Chin to the
eyeball.
I'd love to see that.
I was there for that one.
Yeah,
that was like 97 that was the early days of the UFC and I remember thinking,
Oh shit,
do you remember that dude?
When,
when they would have it in a parking lot somewhere and I would always come with
you and we just sit there and it was just such a different,
well we were in Louisiana once you,
me and Ricky rocket and Eddie Bravo.
Yeah.
Ricky rocket was taking Gj recovery.
Ricky,
Ricky like legit black belt.
I'm really shadows,
legit black belt like roles.
He's very good.
And uh,
I know you're like skeptical Hipaa face with them,
but uh,
we were all in like Fox somewhere in Louisiana or some shit.
Right?
Where the hell were at Baton Rouge Rouge,
I think it was something like that.
Meeting you at the airport and just like,
let's go.
And I would just be walking around with these guys.
It's just children who are just fans of the time.
You weren't working,
it was working.
We were doing the post fight interviews.
John [inaudible] seven.
God Damn Dude,
I've been in the late Joe and I admit,
I remember you and I walking like I like little school boys.
Randy couture was sitting there being interviewed.
I,
I remember the show well and you and I kind of added up.
We kind of like stood at a little bit of a distance and just stared at him and
I,
and of course you know me,
I was like to her,
I was like,
what did his shoulders,
he doesn't look that big.
His arms,
his leg looked at his leg and he had a ball boy on his knees.
Like late isn't that big?
And we're just like looking at what a bad ass he was.
Just this body forged speakers.
Nice Hallway.
You guys are around next weekend.
Are you for this?
I leave Sunday night.
Sunday,
Saturday night for Australia.
So Saturday night we could do,
if I companion for this,
that's a big fucking cock.
Oh No,
no,
no.
You know what?
I'm going to be in that.
Wait,
what is that?
Because I'm going to be an Irvine to third and eighth.
Oh,
I'll be here.
Yeah.
Dude.
June 8th night everybody come see me.
This is a legit fight.
Oh my God.
Is it is a legit facts.
Holloway has a legit chance.
I think Mex wins.
You think so?
Yeah.
I like maths in this fight.
Wow.
I don't like that.
You know.
I don't know why he's not getting more respect.
I don't Max.
Yeah,
he's a fucking killer.
She's getting a ton of respect.
You don't think Max gets it?
A lot of our spa,
not like he should or the press.
I liked the fact that he's willing to fight him in fucking Rio to man the
doesn't care.
He doesn't give a full book.
Talk about just an incredible champion though.
All know.
Well you know what man,
all those legacy in his reign is always going to be tarnished by that 13 seconds
against Mcgregor,
which is so crazy and a bit cause you take away that fight and he's got one
brutal war with Chad Mendez where he got rocked and stunned,
which is a tough fight to him about part two.
Yeah.
The second one would be the one of the best fights.
Welcome.
Great fight.
And then those are like the only hard moments he's had inside the octagon.
Really.
Other than like maybe round five against Ricardo Lamas.
Member lamas had them down and it was doing a little bit of ground and pound the
fifth round.
But that was like all the,
was too drained,
making that weight.
But he's smaller now,
you know,
he generally looks smaller.
He definitely,
uh,
chose to slim down and because,
yeah,
because he was,
had unbelievably brutal weight cuts early in his career.
He was just too big for the weight class and so he just chose to a slim his body
down your boy Vito fights nape mark hard on that flip and that's his last fight
in the UFC.
And then he says he's going to go elsewhere.
Time for the return of T.
I can't wait.
He's going to Japan son,
Godzilla movies.
Go to Japan and fight super heavyweight.
He's going to get to 40 and celebrate that and just happen to everyone with his
chin and the fucking shit.
You can't find the chin,
the eyeball thing.
Damn it.
Didn't find it.
Mark Kirk was in UFC 14,
which would be on fight pass,
which I'm signing up for.
Oh,
okay.
Beautiful.
Um,
yeah man.
I like to see [inaudible] comeback and uh,
she was still the guild.
Juicy Gills,
Cro,
cop,
heavyweight.
Well,
sign me up.
What's going on in rise in is like,
it's all on the table.
You know,
this is not,
there's no funny business on the table.
A man do what you gotta do.
Everything's good just for recovery,
Bro.
Just working for recovery.
Need recovery.
It's important your recovery.
You need yellow eyeballs.
Remember when Ben Johnson won the Olympics and his eyeballs were yellow cause
his liver was processing so much steroids.
Oh my God.
I just,
I don't know till whites of his eyes were yellow.
Really yellow.
Yellow's was Ben Johnson and Johnson,
the one who won the gold medal and was the first like real publicly shamed
steroids.
Do you remember how fast,
how he pulled away from Carl Lewis and everybody?
Just what you remember what he looked like,
by the way,
Carl Lewis was on steroids to correct all of them.
Were his and Ben Johnson just better,
well,
he just took way too much.
Took it to the Simpson.
Yeah.
He just,
I don't know what Carl Lewis was on,
but I do know Carl Lewis tested positive for quite a few things.
When I started researching the history of doping,
when I had Victor Conte on from the Barco scandal and the ultimate,
the ultimate super snitch,
he's the super snitch of all time.
And then talking to Lance Armstrong and understanding like,
and then going into,
I watched maybe five or six documentaries on,
on drugs and sport,
get your masters if you watch that many documentaries,
when I feel the college degree,
I watched three of them and be like,
I got this.
I got them.
Ask If,
so what I did take out of it was that like according to Victor,
Kanye,
all of the track and field athletes are dirty.
It's more prevalent than track and field
track and field 100% what he was saying essentially was that what Ben Johnson
did was get caught.
But there was a lot of people that do it and not only were they doing it,
but it was coordinated by coaches who was coordinating part of the game.
And I say this all the time,
I think it's just part of professional sports.
It really is.
I'm not saying your favorite guys doing it,
but you know the,
the odds are there's a lot of these guys that you see on TV are doing it.
Do you guys think that there's this part of the game steroids in boxing?
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah,
that's a serious question.
Well don't you understand that Shannon Briggs just got pulled out of his world
title fights per test and he's 45 he's 45.
I'm talking about like,
cause not to say,
I'm not saying anybody's doing it,
but when I watched the Kell Brook or all spans fight great fight by the way.
Amazing fighters spends on it.
Athlete New World Champs,
Right Doug?
Yeah,
that's right on an athlete in his domain and he got it kind of boxed up for the
first few rounds.
But winning those firsts when the,
when they brought up the scorecard and like,
God,
I disagree.
I feel like broken.
Well I agreed with what's his face?
Uh,
Steve Farr firewood.
Is that his name?
Steve Farr.
Hood,
firewood.
And each time what that brought up the,
he's the herald letter of enough showtime a lot better though.
You like them better?
Yeah.
You're like,
all right everybody,
here we go.
Jesus Christ.
It's not a bad crash.
It's so intense.
It throws me off.
But that fight was great.
I had,
I had Kell Brook right in there that round seven.
He was still doing work around or two away at least.
And then Spence just put it on them and those body shots were ruthless and his
endurance is incredible.
They,
my favorite part is if you go back and listen carefully to the corners,
they pulled out at the same game plan.
All right.
We just got again,
pass the 10th round and then we're gonna put it on him and they go to the other
corner.
Let's just get past the 10 and then it's all you baby.
Yeah,
they both say the same thing.
Well,
Kell Brook.
Dot.
That Spence was just not experienced enough and didn't have the cause.
He's been knocking everybody out and he's really been,
he's only done 10 rounds and his corner fell.
A Kell Brook cut too much weight.
Yeah.
So they were like,
look,
this guy fucking not to go Lufkin and one 60 like he's going to be struggling
here.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Very interesting now,
nor dental lab.
Who's the boy fighting the man that that's a really,
nor dean to lab is a bad ass.
Fucking Stryker.
I do not know this gentleman,
but he looks dangerous.
Here's like a doodle.
He's a car.
18 years old.
Here it is.
Yes.
I know.
This is not,
this is not the fight.
It's a different fight because that is not a god Damn Boba Shit.
That's crazy.
That's all.
It's natural.
Damn mobish is the guy to look.
Yeah.
Dan mobish.
I forget who that guy is.
That guy's a karate guy though.
He's wearing a karate guy and he fucked up.
Yeah,
I got it.
Got Super smashed.
He's this.
He's that.
I'm Mochi.
Horenstein ah damn.
How could is my fucking UFC memory?
This kid looks like Krav Maga guys from nothing.
Seven.
Have you seen this?
The 35 year old fight in the 19 year old here.
What's going on here?
It's the [inaudible] lab is a beast,
man.
Gotta check 35 year old.
You gotta check your head.
What are you doing in your head?
You're fine.
You look normal knowing cause he's an actor.
He's an actor.
Makes his living off his face.
Well we don't have anything coming up.
It's such an odd character.
This Brian Strange Bird.
Strange bird.
Like
what is this Doug Davidoff talk dovetails.
Just tough guys.
Tough guy.
Like what the fuck you saying?
Okay,
so here's damn boat,
which look,
see,
he gets on top of him.
Fuck.
See,
fighting Bobas was a tank to a big old strong man looking dude.
So he gets on top of them and watch what he does with his Chin is a beer.
He gets the chin.
I believe he pressed his face up against the cage.
Who went for a head on now,
here it is right here.
Right here.
Chin.
Right to the Isat.
Get Dude.
You know how bad that would fucking smush and he's covering his eyes.
Fucking Christ.
Big John McCarthy.
Yeah.
That's where you want to quit.
That's a legit move.
I wonder if you can still do that.
The challenge in the eye and I'm using it and my next door neighbor said that.
But no,
you can't touch the eyes.
There's nothing.
You're not touching it.
You're just holding onto him sneaking the Chin into the eye socket recently.
What'd you say,
Jamie?
There's another fight in a form that said it happened in two.
I don't.
Interesting guys.
Algin correct.
There was a fight recently with your Chin Sorta,
but I mean isn't it an eye gouging when you shoved her knuckle in there?
Yeah.
Which is also illegal,
but when you knuckle,
when you punch someone,
but that's unintentional.
Is it short?
Is trying to punch him in the eyeball,
try and punch me with other things.
But Haysman beat Elvis and no cinesync
belt.
It was a while ago.
That's interesting because Elvis is a Machado black belt.
What's this commercial?
But by the time you're,
you know,
in that position and of course to fuck was going on here.
Christopher Walken,
what are you selling?
Five calories.
Um,
what was the,
what was the fight recently in UFC where,
where the guy was covering the other guy's mouth so he couldn't breathe.
That sounds brutal.
Brutal.
And time.
I mean,
that's not that bad.
No.
Bj Penn,
you do that all the time.
That's how he used to get guys to,
uh,
he would cover their mouth when he took their back and then they would try to
stop that and then he would grab their arm with his leg and then he would choke
him.
Ken Anderson,
Anderson Silva.
It's good.
Common move.
Yeah.
That's pretty common.
I don't use it.
How's it going?
Use it.
I tried doing her.
Doug Davidoff use it as a master.
Who's doing it there?
Chris Haysman.
Elvis.
Elvis in a sick,
that's the shit.
That whole just wore back a little bit with this.
No holds bar TV.
Oh yeah.
This is no gloves too.
Yeah.
Elvis might not have even been a black belt back then.
He's tapping.
Oh Jesus.
He's tapping to the eyeball to eyeball.
Damn.
Chris Haysman also had a fucking wicked front lake sidekick.
He's one of the first guys in MMA.
They figured out how to use our front leg side kick.
Well like I just fucking poked his out and had a flat top so it gets the win
there.
That's Haysman flat top pace speaking advice.
Did Kell Brook hurt the same break?
The same orbital?
No different than one tip.
And I hear he's got titanium,
I guess.
Is that for the titanium from triple g?
Yeah,
he got boxed up.
God maybe it's good to have two titanium eyes and then the other one broken too.
Did he break his left leg keep too,
I feel like he did.
His addiction needs similar thing.
Yeah,
that was a bummer man.
I mean he's,
I was all flattened out but he also could have been like really paranoid about
it because of the triple chins.
What I think cause he went back surgery,
he's like,
I'm not losing my left wider.
That's fine.
It's always in your mind.
And by the way,
you don't know what kind of vision damage he suffered.
Like a guy like Bisping's tough as fuck.
He will tell you he's got bad vision in his right eye.
I mean you won't hear someone come to a fight or analyze a fight about bisman
go.
And he's also doing it with one and a half eyes.
Like it's well known knowledge like you suffering.
But what is the deal?
Because back in the day,
like if you had like a detached retina or something,
like they wouldn't let you fight.
No,
because he's got,
so I talked to him a little bit about it.
He's got oil now,
I don't want to fuck this up
so he can't really fix it yet.
He's takes his it.
Yeah,
because if he gets another shot then it could do more damage.
So,
and I don't know if the,
I think it kind of came up with the thing with GSP to,
it's his medical that has something to do with his eye.
It came out,
now it's,
we talked about it.
He's got a,
what's called a floater in his eye.
It's like,
it's like a little bit of damage.
There's something going on with his eyeball.
And that was the holdup is skewed to fight.
I hate when people,
it's like,
well,
do you have see knew about it?
Everybody knew about it,
but they were hoping that they could fix it.
And I believe they gave some injections to his eye.
They tried to repair it.
It's not like threatening his vision.
It's not like a permanent issue.
It's a time issue.
So this guy,
something needs to heal.
This guy cut zero weight and the other guy cut 30 pounds.
You don't know.
I don't know.
But I liked the way that guys throwing it's old school karate sidekicks a warm
up.
I like mark as a ref.
Did they?
Uh,
how old is this kid?
Did they say?
I think they said he's 19 now.
He's 25.
20 new.
Wow.
Is He?
Yeah,
he's just,
Oh,
you just said he's nice town.
But I mean,
I'm sorry sir.
But excuse me.
It's the UFC be all right.
But um,
what,
what's going on?
Who's the youngest guy to ever fight in the UFC?
I want to say it's Dan Lozan for it.
Yeah.
I think Dan.
No.
[inaudible] 19 I think Dan Lozano was 18 how old was sage?
Northcutt 22 um,
nor dean to the guy in the red shorts is a bad ass striker.
Amazing striker.
I tried to start very fucking technics.
Super Freak.
Super Technical.
Look at that.
Look at that beautiful movement.
Yeah.
He's,
he's elite shit.
This youngster,
he fucking around kid guys.
It's really bad.
Back to he laughed at it.
He's very karate based though.
You could tell,
but him throwing that,
that kick.
You don't,
how old was the Joe Lozan when he fought Jens Pulver on that short notice?
I'm going to say he was 20.
He might've been the youngest.
Not,
no,
I don't think so.
Not Man's composed.
Oh yeah.
He knocked out Jens Pulver the left Hook,
right?
Yep.
Oh,
that.
And he's a huge underdog.
Gotcha.
Loads on.
Still doing the damn thing too.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Joe Lowe's smart as shit to super smart guy.
Yeah.
I mean easily could have been like some it tech guy.
Really?
Yeah.
But he said Chunky for adrenaline.
He's a beast video game guy too.
This guy is definitely taekwondo guy.
Say That guy's name and camp.
I don't think it's taekwondo,
man.
I think it's karate.
I could be wrong,
but you know the thing of the problem with saying it's taekwondo versus karate.
He's like a really depends on who's teaching a kick,
right?
Dax like taekwondo,
but oh,
but a lot of good showed pecan guys.
They throw kicks that way too.
The,
Ooh Norton.
It's chewing up that leg.
That hurt him too.
That bothering the way.
Nordine kicks in much bigger.
I'm taekwondo.
I don't,
I mean he's definitely more muscular,
but he's,
I don't think he's much bigger,
much heavier.
Walking around.
He'd lay his frame.
He just looks at price,
walks around at 200 pounds.
Whereas this guy walks around at one 70 well,
he also looks like a man or was there,
the kid looks very young to keep monetizing that Logan movie.
That shit is so depressing.
Is it?
Oh my,
it's wolverine with cancer.
He can through life.
He's a limo driver.
I'm not interested in oil or he's a Goddamn limo driver.
Stop.
Don't do this to me.
Well,
I'm trying to help you guys out.
You'd want to see a couple of people told me that the alien movie sucks and I
almost don't like told you that I'm a piss down their throat.
It's the best movie I've seen this year.
Feel best fucking,
I was so excited.
Me and you were crunk for that.
I saw.
I have a 15 month old,
so it's hard for me to see movies.
I got a babysitter.
I saw it opening night.
I standing ovation.
That's what I want to hear.
I got my cheated on my Twizzlers at dice code is trying to get the take down
here with a weird move.
It's we know shit's going on with the second one again.
It's like fuck it.
Don't lives man.
Maybe he's got a good ground game.
You remember I'm Gunnar Nell's.
Ooh,
that's a beautiful trip.
Hey,
Pass too.
I'm very jealous.
I control has that crazy karate style.
Go to Nelson with some sort of a karate champion before he was into a world
champion.
He's a picky Steiger.
He heard what this kid has come.
Oh Shit and camp.
We need to sleep on this kid talking about pretty boy in camp.
Do this kids built like Doug Davidoff.
That's exactly right.
Brian won't shut up about their bodies.
How I think about Jenna,
Brendan,
I have,
I have neurosis.
I have deep seated.
Neurosis is breaking down.
Yo kind of watch that back.
Heck,
that's not what we practice.
Not really.
Telegraph sat back kick.
Yeah,
don't move that front foot.
Just turn your shoulders man.
Oh good.
You're running in there.
Careful.
Now you should give him advice me.
Well I was,
I was breaking down Yolanda Whitaker and Brian goes with the,
with those pegs you think,
oh Geez,
you know what?
I'm going to do this another time.
I was dead serious.
I wasn't wearing pants either.
Oh,
this kid.
Oh look at this fucking exchange.
Good exchange of knees here this day and age,
you really don't get to the UFC unless you're fucking game game man.
Like anyone who sees.
Can Be really,
really tough.
The level so much higher than it used to be.
You know what I'm saying?
You got 50 seconds.
That's what I be saying.
So strollers,
posture,
strong mission control.
Here.
He wrapped that up real quick.
Real quick.
Hey,
the kid going to the has bound the kid really good on the that Center Rubber
Guard gentlemen.
Yes,
correct.
But he's also going for an arm bar here.
The arms wait,
tweet too hard.
Look at the control though.
It's his posture control.
Whoa.
You and I are going.
It's out.
It's like Jesus.
He's in Trello clothes.
Got My blue belt in 2000 guys.
The game's evolved.
Did you get your blue belt in 2000 sure did.
Henzel Gracie,
the heads on Gracie Blue Bell.
What did you think they would let you have it now if you went back to class.
They keep wanting to give him my purple.
Just honorary.
Do you think they would say,
listen man,
you've got to go back to,
why do you guys have to put you back in a while?
I would volunteer that.
Do you ever get like demoted?
Like do you ever get a purple belt?
And then,
oh,
that happened to me when I pushed up the Gracie Kennedy.
They made me wear a white belt for a long time.
I've got a brown belt from someone else.
I was in a white belt for a while.
Who did you ever brown boat from?
Amal Easton.
A mall.
Wait a minute.
A Mall East and give you a brown belt and the Gracies told you you have to wear
white belt and St.
It was just like for the first few weeks just to see what my level is that why
does it,
but you're in a mall,
Easton Brown belt that is very,
very legit.
That's not like Freddie Mercury.
Some fucking dude.
The Midwest,
the other Freddie Mercury St Mustache.
We'll have a lot in common.
When I trained in Brazil too,
they made me wear light belt.
What?
I feel like that's so disrespectful.
You have a brown belt from you should they should say from who?
Amal Easton.
Oh,
okay.
Come on in
tribal though.
And it's so,
yeah,
but that's the same tribe.
Yeah,
it's a Henzel Gracie black belt.
I think it was more just like,
I don't know.
I had no issue with it.
I literally do not care.
But I would tell guys if they didn't know who I was as like,
yeah,
I'm not a white belt,
and I'm just like,
I know we go on,
I'm not a white belt brother.
He's be like,
no,
we can make fucking ears,
man.
Yeah.
But I mean,
dude,
that's just,
I don't understand that.
It was only for like two or three weeks.
Was this one you were in the UFC?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Everyone can.
I most people knew,
you know,
just doesn't make any sense.
Yeah,
that seems really weird to me.
I went to that a beginner's class and fuck them up.
Don't just to
me 10 yellow belts.
I don't like you doing your mood.
I don't like you doing that somersault move on me.
It's annoying.
What was that thing you just did to me?
Somersault,
move and he just grabbed me
and I and that's,
that's where I sustained or he just got robbed.
Oh Jesus.
Great check left hook boy.
Just kids winging these guys are kid.
It was a great fight,
man.
Break out.
Do you still have that Tesla?
Yes,
I do and I love broken down at all.
No Dude,
it's my favorite car.
I'll never have another car.
I'm a test a man.
Sam Harris is Tesla broke down twice on him.
Why Tay?
I love hearing that.
Left them stranded in a wet hair and that.
Yeah,
he had like a full charge and it said pull over immediately.
Your car is not safe to drive and it's like why?
It's annoying.
My Tesla is impeccable.
I'll never have another one.
I'm a Tesla guy.
Just like I'm a,
I'm a front foot side kick guy.
I'm a Tesla guy.
Front foot's.
Yeah,
I mean only in street fighting because it's sneaky.
I haven't even opened up.
I'm Brendan with my kicks yet.
You want to want to get you?
I want to get an older Porsche man.
That's why I'm in the market for,
I believe you were talking to me about it.
Don't you fuck with those targets?
No.
I want a car that makes noise when you drive it.
I don't care.
The wind whistling in.
Those things are shifting.
It's going to be fun,
man.
If you give this one,
this one's redundant.
Has It?
Has a bunch of new stuff.
You're going to get it.
You are,
you're already,
you're,
did I look at it?
Maybe.
Did I send that text from the dealer?
What year is it?
It's a 88.
Did you drive it?
No,
they tried like,
shit,
it doesn't matter.
This one's new.
It's a bunch of modifications.
Yeah.
Puncture.
If Brendan has something in his head,
if he starts talking about it isn't going to happen.
It's going to help with these older cut.
Like I've looked at a few now.
It's just,
it's just like a weekend driver.
Yeah.
Um,
what do you recommend for a Porsche?
Do you want to get a used one,
Brendan?
78 there's some really good used Porsches like you.
I mean,
even the early models,
they're really fun to drive,
but you got to know what you're getting into.
Yes.
You don't want a lemon.
And those cars are really,
they're really fickle.
Like when you turn it,
like say if you're making a turn and you're on the gas,
if you let up off the gas,
they'll oversteer like the back half ass end of the car will come out on it.
No,
it's a far cry from the,
you know,
a new Porsche,
something like that.
New Twin Turbo.
That nine nine one that you use to drive like that is as modern as it gets.
I mean those things are glued to the fucking road.
I agree.
But this one,
this one that's,
the modifications can be sick.
I like the old school vibe to borrow my car for a day.
You'll throw that other car on the trash.
Your gt three.
Yeah.
You'll light that 1987 shitbox on fire.
Hey Bro,
the dealership
dealership fucking lows things to for like that dad uses to start a fire on one
of those,
you know,
love it.
Or are those Coleman grills for camping?
Squirt it all over the car and light it on fire.
Dude,
I saw someone in a brand new gt three it was purple.
The GT three Rs.
Yeah.
They make them fucking purple.
Those are those cars.
Mass dealer.
So dot.
Oh my God,
I'm was sick.
They finally make it with a manual transmission again.
Finally the 2007 nor dean to lab side control the 2017 so you could finally get
them in the manual transmission work complaining.
Well it's Porsche was trying too hard to just get lap times and people were
pissed and they were complaining like what the fuck does a gt three how come
it's a double clutch?
Well how come I can't get it with a manual transmission?
So finally they um,
they released this thing,
the nine 11 r which was essentially like a gt three without the wing.
Good luck getting that thing.
People are selling them for like half a million dollars in more.
They only made how many hundred or 911 crazy.
They made 911 and the light with the stripes.
Yeah.
But now they're saying that this new gt three,
the manual one that you could actually just buy is actually better than the nine
11 are cause the reason the automatics,
the PDK is it's,
you know it's faster than humans will track time.
We can't keep up with do you mean faster than humans?
Like shifting stuff like that.
The computer does computers better track time and it's instantaneous.
It has two clutches so it has one clutch that's in like say if you're in first
gear,
there's one clutches in first gear.
The second clutch is already engaged in the second gear.
So would you hit it?
It's instantaneous.
Like Bam,
like the,
so you don't have to shift it.
It takes shifting out of the gate.
You can have it in automatic and it'll shift for itself.
Or you can have it in manual and you shift with the paddles but you don't have
to push the clutch in so you're not pushing your left leg.
That kind of takes away from the trials.
Yeah,
the fun you will find it.
The driving feeling get automatic.
I though my Porsche had those,
the panels is lame and thinks about computers and stuff where they,
they take out the tactile enjoyment and the,
the timing and the human timing and all that.
It,
it,
it Kinda makes it not that much fun anymore.
I would imagine with your car it may,
it really makes a big difference unless you're on a race track.
Like if you're on a race track and you're just trying to get zero to whatever,
you know,
zero to 60 times and make sure that your,
your lap times are quicker,
then you want something that shifts instantaneously.
But those are also to put up numbers cause like the new viper they see are
compared to the new Porsche,
the lap times,
they don't wanna look bad so they can put their best foot forward.
Well the problem with the Viper is a viper is a standard.
It's a manual transmission,
but it's so fucking fast.
It doesn't matter.
They bring that viper ACR to every track and they go,
hey,
we're here to break the new track,
record the fuck out of the way.
We have the most ridiculous car America has ever built.
It's got wings all over it.
She's a student.
Whenever we talked about this,
the same guy shoots me Dan and he's like,
it's a picture of the viper hair.
It is man for this price and like,
oh it's like a little jarring.
Scott's it got Eylea so you're,
you're just drawn that that has no Lord.
I mean you're drawn to it like a huge engine like pissy pull up viper ACR.
This is do nothing for Brian.
Listen,
we're going to need this,
which I don't get cause you like sleep mask and stuff.
I like masculine stuff.
They got a Tesla.
You've never driven one.
That's the problem.
You drove the testimony like Ah,
now finally I know what it's like.
It's got Kik and no lag.
It doesn't even make sound.
Don't know when this understand about lag.
I don't settle for lag.
Lag.
Yeah.
Like it's a racing term.
I didn't know.
Look at this car,
Brian Callan given some volume and look at that here.
Then the aluminum on that bad boy and the fence.
It's gotta be fiber is a guy who knows nothing about cars.
It's got a v 10 feet,
10 under three same horsepower clamps.
Can we get some volume on this?
There was no volume.
You don't need falling any Valium?
Just museum.
Why do you want volume?
It's just music press.
You want to hear though?
Whoa,
whoa.
I prefer an a silent assassin.
I called my test site.
The class for you be,
Oh God,
this car.
What could this?
Here we go.
You have no idea what this is like a giant fin chuck.
Brian,
you have no idea what this feels like.
Bullshit.
Got To be in a car that has this kind of power would change your life.
No Way.
Oh,
you don't understand?
If you drove that thing,
it would change your life.
You'd get out of it your hand to be sweaty.
Your balls be tingling.
you.car 13 times more testosterone than when you got into the car and get that
step left you fuckers.
You got in that car and then went and dead lifted.
You'd be stronger.
I'm not kidding.
That car.
So American America as well.
And have an ego like a trans am.
What's that?
What's that going to cost me?
That's 150 which is a good 263
tremendous deal.
You think of what the fuck that thing is?
It does look like,
like if you like an ego,
like let's make it seconds.
No,
it looks like a snake.
I think they're going to discontinue it.
I think this is the last year which bums me out,
man to the fact they're making something like this.
They'd say it's so much better than the corvette.
We've got three minutes and other qualified boy.
Well the new Corvettes are pretty bad ass,
but they say that once you drive this,
he'd go all the Corvettes.
Trash.
God Damn.
This is going to sound like a weird thing to say.
A little bit like an asshole pulling up in that though.
I feel like an asshole poem for my GG three na,
but I do it.
I parked it out front.
The company
is end camp a
a.
Is he a sweet Sweden?
Yeah.
It's going to sound weird,
but he's gotten bigger.
As the fight progressed.
I feel like he's,
I feel like he's just somehow that this is chosen return.
I feel like he looks like a Swedish Wonderboy Thompson.
Yes he does.
I think all the blood that's in your Dick is fucking with your vision.
What are you trying to say and why is tell labs shorts had been hiked and they
haven't come down.
Who wants to show us the talk?
Well you can get the different cuts be you know.
Well you know that that's what thing that Muy Thai fighters too.
They always pulled her shorts up but that stayed up.
That's interesting.
It's almost like glue it up at us.
Quad son.
Good low kick there.
Tell you what man and camp my,
did you hear the rumor they're trying to make Francisca no jds late summer.
Oh No.
For who?
What do you think JD?
You know that song?
I thought they were trying to jerk.
Lewis of Derrick Lewis gets by Mark Hunt.
Oh he can't kill a few to soaring young black by
Derrick Lewis is talking about your shit about him.
He called him an error.
African booty scratcher.
Scratch.
Lewis is my,
one of my favorite UFC fighter too because,
and not just because of his fighting style,
but also because of his Instagram page.
It's hilarious.
Derrick Lewis has the best sense.
He goes hard.
Hey,
when he beat Travis Browne,
you went so hard in the paint coming up to this girl.
Just also Larry.
He's a funny fucking dude,
man.
Some nerve talking shit to Francis,
the fucking terminator.
He scares the shit out of me.
He's so true.
Stories with braids that let's not get too crazy in Chicago with brains.
Right for me right now.
No,
no,
no.
You're,
you're on this bullshit.
No,
no,
no.
He's on another level.
Who's he beat?
How's going to beat our last game?
It's just not who we beats.
He how he beat some dude.
He's so big.
You don't understand like check Congo was a bad motherfucker in his day,
but check Congo wasn't starching people the way.
God No is he did when he first burst on the scene.
People Forget.
We get on these type down pat Barry in a crazy wild slug fest when he was
already hurt.
You know what I mean?
That was a super impressive victory.
He's got some good and some good victory Kongo fight.
Roy Nelson.
Yes.
Roy Nelson knocked him the fuck out.
That's a bad example.
There's a whole week.
Do you ride?
It was just like this.
Roy.
Roy knocked out a lot of fun to it.
Now do you think Roy Mitrione rematch and Belgium drone tweeted today?
Hey,
how bout we fight after I get through fate or like you better focus on fate or
Matt.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Hey,
real quick.
Roy Fade or fight.
Surprise had on dad who won this fight.
I wonder,
this is,
this is interesting.
We're just doing at the viper now I'm talking about France,
you know,
to soaring.
You don't understand why
the idea that a viper is a stimulating experience.
Yeah.
I have no experience with those kinds of cars.
You haven't been in my test,
so when I've opened her up did I have a bit of driven tests now feel about that
very fast.
I like them.
Yeah.
Greg do not.
I just don't like,
I don't like the fact that they run out of batteries quick.
Yeah.
I don't like the fact that Sam Harris has left him stranded twice.
That's weird.
It's not weird.
I think for a guy who's not a car guy like me who doesn't get off on the,
my mom,
you know,
I liked that I don't have to go to a gas station and got more issues charging
like you're like,
God,
I got to find somewhere to charge.
It is an issue all the time.
He'll be like,
let me draw your a scatterbrain.
You'll probably want those guys doesn't charge car for you.
Yeah.
That's not a car scattered.
Right?
Like there's a gas station everywhere.
Yeah.
When you charge at my house.
That's it.
Yeah.
You just plug it in.
There's superchargers.
Supercharged,
supercharged,
but good luck finding him safely.
Drive the Improv and you're like,
fuck,
I need to charge.
What do you do?
You've got some issues.
I,
I've,
I've call up a rich made it to my,
I've made it to my driveway with zero battery.
Zero,
like literally zero where I was.
Well that's not as hard as us.
No,
it's terrible though.
Like I,
I drove to Irvine and then I realized halfway back from Irvine or I'm going to
be June 8th and ninth and 10th,
uh,
where I realized halfway through that I was done.
Like I was,
I was not going to make it back so I had to stop and charge it.
And then how long do we have to wait to charge?
Takes forever.
If you don't have a supercharger,
you're,
you're like,
those charges they have in,
in garages are complete bullshit for an hour you'll get,
you know,
18 miles.
Those ones you can stop by on the road or be struggling.
Yeah,
those are great.
Those and a half hour.
You're good.
Where are those were all over?
Not really all over yet,
but I will say this,
that they're trying,
uh,
Tesla's trying to get up stations where you can go in and they switch her
battery out right there.
Let's see.
Guess who want to lead I think.
I think probably to leave the,
we're going to come down to the third round.
Boy they're going hard with this thing because he was on telling you that shit
is so depressing.
What's that logo?
Get the fuck out of my face with the ads are brutal.
Those shows me in the UFC when a fight starts and they have to do an nor dean to
let won the fight starts and they have to do an ad while the fight.
Yeah.
That shit drives me to 11 brought to you by alien.
It drives me crazy is no,
this is very swollen right now.
There you got to hit so you got punched in the nose be Yup.
Dan Hardy.
He's still talking about coming back cause I know he was talking about it for a
while there.
If they could figure out some way to let it come to this team,
this English comm team team.
I really liked these guys.
I never hear them because we're always doing this but I'm sure Dan's excellent.
It's fucking brilliant.
He's really good.
I worked with those guys way back in the day when I was doing shows in England
and they were just sort of like,
they tried out for a while before they actually did it.
You know,
there was some,
um,
some testing that they did.
Oh,
that's a nice check left,
right,
left hook.
They,
uh,
it's a different vibe than you guys.
They really talk,
you know,
they're talking about talking to the fighters the week of,
they sticked a lot of that,
you know?
Yeah.
Everybody's got their own style.
That's so interesting thing about Kotlin.
He's also gust weird style.
The Way He dresses,
I think it's on some 1970.
That's a checklist.
Shit.
Boy,
that shit suit he's wearing.
I'm not mad at you.
I'm not mad at it.
Completely different than your goals would.
That checkered pattern,
what does that called look at it?
I didn't see it.
Oh,
the plan is that plaid?
Yeah.
Nordine or you brought up the Tesla for superchargers in like all of them
that they should have a 24 hour with white p number that you can call if you get
stuck somewhere with white people.
Let's be real.
Who Buys?
Tesla's the only black Friday.
Kind of like me.
The only black guys that drive Teslas,
they're the same black eyes.
They keep their cell phone on the outside of their shirt with a belt hook.
Yeah.
You Shop Channel Super Tech?
No,
no,
no.
The rare black guy that drinks tea.
Any products?
Sure.
It still keeps one of those Bluetooth ear pieces in those ones.
The blue light on it has a lightweight fuck.
Has that belt clip.
Fuck fuck you.
Do you still do you still wear a fanny pack all the time,
bitch.
I would never wear one.
I would want to to run.
I sent Joel Pizza.
It looks strong.
I have three different ones that I wear for running.
That's impressive.
Preme ones with zippers.
Yeah.
Those are good to keep it tight,
but they're not good enough for me.
When I travel,
when I travel,
I need the official hire primate fanny pack.
It's large.
[inaudible] cause my running one doesn't say tiny like flops around to fucking
annoying.
Oh you got to get a better one.
I got some good running ones.
Mine say tide is fun.
Yeah,
I need one.
It's just called the running belt.
I love it.
Let a handsome Bannister who's got a Hoodie on deck.
We got a fighter in the kid hoodie.
That's the Abbot Kinney Fighter Hoodie,
right?
That's right.
Represent man.
I'm surprised the UFC like get back that shit up Jamie.
Show him.
Yeah,
he can't.
Oh Kiss live TV.
Well you can give,
have a little rewind two little regional show his own product.
What happened to action showing you I'm wearing now.
You're sure man in our shit.
Yeah.
You fucking pill.
Do you want to like buy our stuff?
Yeah.
You only need to go like one.
Hmm.
What happened when you do these Joe,
do you don't,
you don't matter.
The studio here in la?
Yeah.
So you don't have to obviously go anywhere.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Not going anywhere.
This.
Let me tell you something,
man.
This is like one of the hardest things that I do is these,
when these fight breakdowns,
because uh,
you ready do some homework?
I not only have to do some homework,
but I do them.
I'm writing them and performing them live.
Like there's no script.
Like I have zero script areas like that.
A strong fighter and the kid Hoodie,
look at that camera.
That's right baby.
You can hunt with it.
You can disappear and fully ready to your spine on your ex.
Shit.
You really don't want to hunt in cotton,
but,
well,
you know what I mean?
It looks good.
We're releasing the hunter additional pure wool.
Well you need to get in with first light and have them make a fighter and the
kid version.
Remember wearing wool like when we were wet and how you could be wet in Alaska
and it was called,
but you'd be in the morning,
you'd be cold,
but you'd put on wet wool and you kept you warm.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Do I want to see Rina?
Yes.
That's the fight.
I feel like I want rose to have a year or two more.
Man.
That's the way it works.
I know the problems.
She's beat Claudia twice now.
Carolino no,
she lost Carolina.
That's how Carol Lena got the fight.
Who did roasted,
oh,
not saying Yolana.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She'd be Claudia twice.
She beat Carolina.
Should beat just gone.
Jessica and trust Jesus Christ as Jessica and tries to have a fucking chin.
That chick is so tough and they were sending me there,
honey.
I'll take an shutout out.
Well,
well she is a tank.
I see.
I wouldn't see my auntie and her and rose Rose A.
Little more warm up,
but that's not the way it works.
There's nothing left for you on that.
I know that there really is nothing left for,
I mean after rose dismantled the karate hottie
mantle that didn't think that was going to happen.
Paid kick to choke.
Whoa.
Good Lord.
I think rose has real legitimate world championship possibilities.
Hello,
which is,
I would just like to see her.
I mean,
look man,
I'm,
I might be wrong.
She might go in there and get her.
She might get you on.
The thing about rose that you can't count out and she's dangerous.
She's more explosive and like more dynamic than any girl out there I think.
Wow.
She's so athletic.
You told me you freak athletic when,
cause we were training together at grudge and man freak freak.
You ever see her do flying armbars yeah,
she's had it been in fights.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
The girl can hit a flying arm bar in a fight.
She has x factor that Yolanda hasn't seen yet,
but if that doesn't happen for golden is a scary,
scary woman striking.
Would you say it's the best and you'll see it as an just,
just flat out right?
Like tech technical.
Wow.
I mean it's definitely the best and women's MMA,
but it's not like she doesn't have the brutal knockout power that like cyborg
house,
which she has is like excellent technique like over and over again.
She's using perfect technique and footwork,
but she,
she needs a volume of punches to get people out.
She's not a big person.
Like she has small hands.
She has small feet,
just small bones.
She's not like,
like in the Jessica and drives fights.
Perfect example on drudge was so scary and every punchy throws us like she's
strong,
these fucking bombs.
Whereas you want us just picking at it on that technique.
She's so much more technical,
more she wasn't stopping in any way on drugs is kind of constant assaulting
pounds.
Yeah.
Literally 150 pound female fight.
You can fight differently too.
Right?
I mean,
obviously you can be more technical,
whereas if you're fighting somebody technical,
I mean,
there's a lot of technique,
but I'm saying I feel like when you would pay very dearly for one shot from
somebody who's bigger,
you almost have to fight differently.
Right?
Yeah.
For sure.
If you're fighting,
mighty mouse is more technical than,
yeah.
You know?
Yeah.
Anybody really?
How about him?
Tj Ain't happening.
It's that TJC.
I'm like,
no,
you've got to pay me.
And you know I love Tj.
I know you probably listening for Dj,
it doesn't make sense for mighty mouse mighty mouse.
It does not make any slots.
Why teachers don't even have the belt.
It's not as super fight.
He wouldn't,
I'm super fights equal super money and when it,
when it's not a needle mover unfortunately as I would love to see the fights of
ridiculous fight.
So what is a,
has mighty mouse had no to it.
Is that what it straight up was like ain't happening.
Wow.
The UFC wants it happened.
He's like,
no,
I'm good.
It ain't happening.
Ray Boards,
the next contender isn't that interesting that that he can make those calls too.
I mean it's one of those weird things.
It's like in boxing,
you know you have mandatory challengers and then you know,
then you try to make super fights in the UFC.
It's like they're like,
hey,
we've got to fight for you.
And he's like,
hmm,
I'm the champ.
Well,
but it's rare,
right?
Like if you only have one title defense,
you better get the fuck up then and played played with us.
You know what I'm saying?
It's a cluster fuck because right now like you have to order like I'm all about
super fights.
We have to have order.
Otherwise,
you know,
think about if Tj went down there,
then what happened with the Cody Garbrandt fight lemons with Dj.
You know what I'm saying?
But this Conor McGregor kind of phenomenon,
everyone's trying to do it.
Yeah.
Well I think TJ just went through a huge camp and he wants a fight,
you know,
I mean he's,
he's gone through this giant camp getting ready for Cody.
I get it.
And you know,
Cody,
they were trying to pressure him to fight.
He,
they even sent him down.
I don't why I sent him down to Germany,
Germany to get the same shit you can get in Santa Monica.
How weird is that?
Well,
Dana doesn't believe that it's the same and I don't understand that.
So,
so what,
what is wrong with Cody?
He's got [inaudible].
Yeah,
he's got a back issue.
What is it do we know he's got something was disk and he needs time off.
He needs spinal decompression and he's got the Regeneca and he went and got a
full treatment.
They say it'd be ready by September.
October.
Yeah.
Got a weight maybe.
But you have to absolutely make sure it heals.
First.
I sent him a bunch of information.
I sent him,
um,
the,
uh,
reverse hyper machine,
send them some stuff on spinal decompression and uh,
he's also talking to Dr. Davidson,
who they're starting to do some stuff and yeah,
he's,
he's brilliant.
They're starting to do some stuff now in the UFC where there,
um,
the stem cell doctors are now going to inject stem cells into discs and they're
going to regenerate disc tissue.
That's cool.
That's amazing.
This is the first time.
Yes,
yes.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
They've got shit.
They've got studies that they've done enough of them now that they have some
real good evidence that it does regenerate.
Same way it regenerates cartilage and ligaments and,
but there's a lot of times with the injuries where,
you know,
sometimes that's not going to be enough.
You're right.
It depends on the injury.
A lot of times those stem cells,
it's just sometimes you fuck a lot of that is that there hasn't been that much
conclusive evidence,
for example,
that it grows and when you shoot it into something I've Koby Bryant would beg to
differ necessarily regenerate sometimes you know,
or a lot,
well it's,
it's very difficult to say why it works on some people and why it doesn't work
on other people.
But I think it's one of these,
yeah,
case by case.
But I think one factor is whether or not you come back too quick and that's what
would Cody did.
Cody got the stem cells and then started working out like four days later.
I keep,
you can't do that.
That's not smart.
You can't do that.
I mean,
you know like look,
he's got a fight,
he's got a big title fight and you,
you,
I think actually it took two weeks off or something like that.
But you need like months and he had a lot of time off.
You need to have your body heal.
It's a very difficult area to heal and a lot of people don't do it correctly.
And then they wind up getting some serious atrophy where the nerves get pinched,
the swelling and all the inflammation and Cody needs to take it slow,
come back and in that TJ fly to be there.
But you can't rush that fight.
We'll look at Eddie.
I mean Eddie Bravo is a,
he has a fake disc in his back down.
I mean,
I shouldn't say fake.
It's artificial.
It's a titanium articulating disc that he had put into his back because of this.
The same issue,
like disc degeneration,
having those injuries constantly training and rolling.
Never really letting it heal.
K or cane hitched surgery.
Yes.
On more than one occasion.
Yeah,
on his desk.
He didn't do the,
and he's still not back.
I mean canes,
there's no fight lined up for cane and Cain steep on.
Maybe that would be the device that would be the fight,
but I mean if your cane mean Jesus Christ,
he's been out for ever.
Excuse me.
A tough fight for him.
Yeah,
a real,
just a fight to make though.
Dude.
Steep pays just,
he's a monster right now.
He's in Bruce Kane is,
I mean,
especially if it's a like a healthy cake ready to go to.
It's the best fight in a long,
long time at heavyweight.
Oh Man.
Are you kidding me?
I was calling lesbian,
I think.
Yeah,
I would have loved to seen that fight in his prime canes,
prime and steep Steve Bay right now.
Like people would go out.
It came over the hill,
came beat the brakes off Travis Browne.
He looked at him.
Travis is obviously no punk like he'd be,
he looked fucking great.
Yeah.
I think,
I just think the guy needs rest.
I'm really thinking a little bit more than that.
He's got a cumulative injuries for sure,
but those were because he's rushing.
They can't rush in the camp,
so maybe if he takes all this time off,
they fight at the end of the year.
We get a prime cane versus a prime Steve Bay sign me the fuck up.
Just came that Mary,
how old is he?
He's still fairly young.
I think he's 32 he's not that old.
Wow.
Yeah.
He just,
he puts his body through the ringer and his fighting style is a grinding style
that's going to catch up where you were showing that video of him doing a kettle
bells with those really heavy weight that he was probably training a little bit.
He,
he fucked up and he had a bad strength and conditioning coach for sure.
And he's got,
that guy got criticized hard core by people that are like really in the know
about technique and back rounded or Kettlebell swings.
It was more of like a like a,
it was like almost like a shrug.
If I got 200 pounds,
I'm crazy.
And chocolate balls,
injuries,
tub.
No,
that's definitely not helping.
it's not helping.
There's a lot of fun.
As he corrected that.
Does he have a better,
I dunno,
you know,
you'd have to talk to Kane,
but all all bullshit aside.
He,
in my eyes,
he's one of two of the greatest heavyweights of all time.
He got fade or,
and you got cane for me,
he's one of two.
Well,
but also it's steep.
A fade or cane.
Steve Bay's resume.
I mean he's top three of all time.
Yeah.
Well were doing was right up there until Steve Bay knocked him out.
No for doom submitted fade or he submitted Minataro and he submitted cane.
He submitted three of the top five and looked it looked great against Travis
Browne.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
twice three of the top five heavyweights of all time.
Uh,
p s flight card in July got over him for doom rematch.
That first one was strike Strikeforce or that one.
The third one's trilogies.
Right.
That's one strike Strikeforce.
I watched the other night a soap or a terrible fight or Jim's sitting there
fucked his knee up real early in the fight.
Real early.
Terrible fight though.
Yeah.
What a what a crazy.
A rematch.
So that's kid.
It'd be a fun one in it and over.
It has been knocked out so many times in his career.
Oh Dude.
I just feel like,
I don't know,
it just gets to a point where you're just like,
to what,
when are you going to realize that you're taking serious punishment?
I think Dutch people are different.
I think they could just keep getting knocked out.
I feel like he's all right.
He's the one guy.
That's all right.
I don't know.
This is the thing be you say that when you watch him fight for doom,
you will and you'll be sitting fucking front row clapping when he knocked out.
My fans are like this,
like I can't,
he keeps getting knocked out when that motherfucker fight one tunes and
unnecessarily Ashley,
come on be overeating.
Not In anymore.
There's one fight away.
He just fought for a title.
He went on a win street.
I don't care.
Oh Bullshit.
I really don't.
I don't find it that exciting.
If it's a worldclass tracker,
I dub dub dub would light a lot of guys out,
but here's the thing,
the best heavyweight striker of all time over him.
You won't want to watch him fight,
but that title,
right?
No,
he just went for a title and knocked I STP on is,
as I understand,
he fought for a title.
He's the best striker in the UFC.
I understand,
but if you could pull up how many times have been knocked out in the past two
years?
It's done a bunch.
It's tough to watch.
It's two years.
Not really.
And there's a lot the past two years,
Jay,
like there is,
it's,
I don't know,
you've got to remember 10 excited.
He fought it.
The bullshit.
You're buying time now.
He fucking fun at the highest level in the world and striking.
So he's going to have more knockouts then of her doom.
Then um,
then all these other guys come to the territory but not so much anymore.
Right.
That's all I'm saying.
I say these two names just don't want to see him get knocked out.
A Guy,
I'll hot sun and I commit off.
That's what I'm saying.
Try doing a spelling bee for those little bitches on tap for this fight card.
That's a beast.
I was looking at it early on.
Well I'm fuck this guys are wrestling,
not a match.
Truong grappling.
See there's like there's,
there's regular strength and then there's Russian dudes strength,
especially Harry Russian dudes strength.
They got here 10% strong.
Good.
I looked at,
I looked at our Laski shoulders on it.
There's hair on the shoulders.
Gotcha.
God Damn it.
That's like extra testosterone.
Dhea too on his back.
Fucked me and I'm smooth as a seal.
Fuck.
That's coming out of his ears.
Like although shaving brush
connected as mustaches.
Oh God damn it.
And then look at that beard for God's sakes.
He's,
he's
straight up.
He's,
he's one of those wind up before you throw a punch.
Guy's like,
he's like digging in.
Some would say stiff.
Yeah,
real stiff.
It's not just a stiffness.
I mean like a lot of these guys,
they could be like more fluid,
but they're trying to knock you out with every shot.
It's almost like a curse to power.
Like it's absolutely beneficial.
There's also a curse to it.
Well,
you can come down so much.
It slows you down so much when you're trying to use it that much.
But the greatness comes to the guys know when to use it.
Right timing.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the most beautiful things that you see in Connor style is how he has none
of that.
Like when he's throwing punches,
unless he's got you fucked up and stunned,
then you're fucked.
Diego Brandao speaking a punches gate G.
Have you seen gates?
He doesn't get you fight Justin Gauges.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He's gonna Fight Michael Johnson.
How good of a hearse fight that?
When is that?
Uh,
June.
Is it June or July?
It was July.
So it's on the job.
It's the ultimate fighter finale.
Oh.
Either way.
It's in that weird span of fights.
Justin Gates,
she just says technique.
Fuck it.
We got two of the big guys from there.
We've got Marlin Mariah's too.
Was also a fucking base three.
He got a gate g you got homeboy.
Who Was the light heavyweight champ?
Middleweight champ.
David Branch.
Yeah,
he came over.
He just one awful fight.
But that's all that it takes a lot of warm up.
Where the fuck did he fight a number nine light heavyweight.
The Russian cat.
Is He Russian creation?
You don't,
I'm talking about flying under the radar,
but either way.
Awful fucking fight.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I remember Morales.
Hey,
do you guys think that the economy,
Mcgregor,
Floyd Mayweather,
the thing is,
is all a hoax and just a way to get Connor to have people talking about him
until he has his next fight.
Like do you think that's just a big,
huge thing to say?
It's marketing ploy.
I think the world's flat too.
You think it's real?
I think me and Joe Bolte don't want to talk about,
I think we're both at red in the face time that no,
I think,
no.
I mean,
do you think he's like an album box?
It's going to happen.
It's going to be what's it's gonna happen.
It's gonna happen.
It's so close.
No,
I'm telling you this.
Why I don't talk to him.
You got one.
There is a current birthing contract to a new podcast called the fighter and the
man,
listen to me.
She's too confusing tracked who was in the UFC and Connor Verde come to an
agreement and we can update them because right now they're in negotiation with
the Floyd Mayweather team.
So Floyd me where the team is going to want an exorbitant amount of money.
They're very patient.
They going to take a long time to drive us out.
Right.
So they can get the best deal.
But essentially the UFC and Connor have come to some sort of promotional
agreement and now they have to figure out how much money Floyd gets and whether
or not they want to gamble on giving him a flat rate of like a hundred million
dollars.
Whatever the fuck he wants.
That's a big whether that's a big like if,
yeah,
but he's also going to want a piece of the pie.
Correct.
They'll be not close to a contract yet.
They're not close,
but they're 90% that's what I'm saying is that I feel like,
oh,
so what happens?
They don't pretend that you have any knowledge of this.
Just do everybody a favor.
I'm yourself.
That's my theory.
Do yourself a favor and don't let your mouth get ahead of life theory that I
believe this is a very smart way of keeping him in align lightheaded.
That's by the way,
let me ask you this.
When,
when,
um,
Tony Ferguson,
and let's just say tiny furniture sending could be fight before that and now,
now somebody is waiting to fight.
Conor,
will Conor fight those guys before he fights Floyd?
No,
definitely not.
So then what happens to the money?
The money right now is in Floyd versus Connor for Connor.
And it's just exorbitant money.
Like he might make,
who knows how many fucking millions of dollars,
maybe a hundred.
Right?
So that's where the real money is for Floyd.
And this is where the real money is for Connor.
So for Connor to jeopardize that by fighting that fucking Russian savage or Tony
Ferguson who also could beat him,
I mean,
I'm not saying he's going to,
but it the off Tony Ferguson is a motherfucking world champion caliber fighter.
So is Habib.
That's a fucking killer fight.
So,
but we don't even know if Khabib can even make one 55 anymore,
man.
He says he can influence by in October.
Right?
Of course there was,
he says he can,
but he didn't make it.
Not only did he not make it this fucking liver shutting down and he had to go to
the Goddamn hospital.
Did you die?
Can we was like,
oh,
but did you die?
Almost,
Did you tie it?
Hey,
get up and make 55 so I can fucking eat my popcorn.
And you fight Tony Ferguson.
Did you die?
Did not get the fuck up there and make the weight for my entertainment.
I just need one fight.
But did you die?
Could be,
whose is that Ken?
That's what I'm,
yeah,
Ken.
Ken Jones.
What did you type love that guy.
He's so fucking funny.
I'm such nice guy.
He's the best.
Does he do stand up?
Yeah,
those little stairs.
A lot of is that doctor right?
The doctor told me he could practice.
He legitimately could practice.
That'd be pissed with shut up.
And that was my doctor.
I'm like,
don't you ever fucking audition to go to,
but fuck this.
I'm not doing anything over one and two in here,
man.
I want a full time guy.
Real Dick car.
That thing was totaled the time.
You can't be real.
Oh,
that's real.
It's now come on.
Cause his real dick.
Yeah.
Hey man,
you think it was like it was he Korean?
What is these Chinese,
I believe,
do you think there's a Korean or Chinese dude with just a fucking egg roll for a
cock?
Just got a big old dumpling.
First of all.
Now there's gotta be some fucking genetic engineering to doing over there.
They're doing that CRISPR thing.
You know that genetic,
uh,
taking embryos and changing their genes,
they're definitely worth on that big dick gene.
They say there are seven years away from the trials where you can have different
hair.
I can't wait.
What if you have like big Dick Gene?
But it only comes with clown feet.
Oh,
the only way you could get big tick is you gotta have fun pictures.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not like fucking double like double her feet.
No feet.
You're doing no sports.
I'd rather have that baby.
Don't swim like a motherfucker.
Oh,
that's true.
You can have your cutting and Maren mountain climbing would be off the charts.
That dorsal fin,
the Fra Cock.
That's not going to help you through the water.
That's true.
Think that fucker ride your like flotation device.
Have you were on some Viagara could actually be a float device.
Agnes bodies.
You can make your Dick Bigger.
There's an operation that no,
only by an inch be right.
Can you cut that cord or something?
You cut the tenant,
but there's also,
I think you can make it thicker too.
There's a whole process.
They pump it up with fat,
but what's going to happen is you're going to have a floppy fat that sounds all
four or this fat deposits the wrong way.
So you've got a big old door knob for a happy,
it all seeps down to the bottom and take.
Looks like it's got to have fucking belly man's penis and transplant operation.
It's a lie.
No,
no,
it's not allowed.
They have done penis transplants now because there's three of them.
I thought that last one in a circumcision
circumcision apparently that the real issue with these transplants is Africa
because African traditional circumcisions or ruthless.
You wanna see one,
I got one of my phone.
You can get her actions already.
Know what they do it with.
Leak their teeth or some shit.
Do it in a bad west as Oregon after I was off traditional circumcision,
don't fuck that up.
Bought
steady hand traditional.
He's like 23 years ago.
Yeah.
Traditional debt and the only dictate could get was white
first one that comes available.
I'll take you.
Would you would take no dick over a white Dick.
Here we go.
Well,
I played a few weeks for a black dude.
That's how they do it.
Press that button.
I don't say I didn't warn you.
What are we looking at?
Traditional circumcision.
It's on his phone.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I told you my Sunday.
Do you want to look at it?
Do it be,
should I not look at it?
I have a family barbecue to go up.
Not Dogs.
Press play.
Why do I have a traditional African circumcision?
I make my phone.
Do you have that?
You want to see Koreans?
I created.
So we look for Brazilian.
Did I ever tell you,
hey,
go watch this.
All right,
hold on.
Hold on.
Okay.
Oh God dammit.
Fuck you man.
Fuck you.
Take that away.
Oh No,
fuck off the stand there.
They have to stand there.
Motionless,
motionless.
That's part of the problem is you fucked me over cause they cut it.
They have to stand there and,
and not react to the pain.
Worse with Joe Joe when he first had internet,
he goes,
I'm like,
what are you doing?
He had his big computer room.
He goes,
all right,
doll that will stay there.
Stay there.
I go,
well what are you doing to me?
He goes,
just stay when I tell you to go,
go.
And he hits play and he runs out of the room and he goes,
now watch.
And I watch and I see this,
I see this beautiful house and this is a Japanese guy.
He's dressed like a Samurai and he's looking at her ass.
He's going,
oh,
ah yeah.
And I'm like,
what's going to go on?
And I hear him going,
all of a sudden you just see this big around pool snake out of this girl's ass.
And the guy starts to eat it and he's going,
he's going to stop.
He's going,
ah,
he's throwing up but laughing at the same time.
I was like,
you sick.
Fuck.
I've ruined forever and I couldn't take my eyes off it profit.
I'll throw up at that stuff.
I can't see that shit.
Dude.
I have,
I'm John Doe.
Hey,
I have John Joseph spoke for you.
Don't let me forget he's signed it.
Okay,
cool.
I turned my car.
Um,
I also have,
uh,
his,
his former partners book here who also really get,
yeah,
hardly wants to get on the podcast,
but they hate each other.
Right.
They stab each other or something.
There's some issues with those guys.
Day Stab Dee.
Charlie's Harley's that I had so black belt now,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
He teaches kids class.
Yeah.
Sad morning.
I started listening to your boy Jockos book.
Oh,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
He's a beast on chocolates.
On Instagram.
There's a video's Christ we played the other day on the Everlast podcast with
Jocko luck explaining how no matter what happens,
good.
Good opportunity to get better.
Good opportunity to grow.
Good time to time to work on things.
Good.
Yeah.
Well frees up more time for other things.
Good.
Oh,
take everything.
Everything good in his videos are in black and white.
Yeah,
he goes,
my inner voice.
Do you want him to keep doing it?
So you know,
I said nothing cause I don't listen to the interval.
I was fired up.
Oh No.
Yeah,
just,
she's such a savage.
I say I'm busy come back later.
But he's a real savage.
Like he's not like,
look,
I'll respect to Gary v,
you know,
like all his motivational videos.
They don't really do it for me the same way.
You know what I'm saying?
I really love Gary Johnson.
No Jujitsu,
navy seal commander,
just matter.
Just still a navy seal and I can't list any,
any motivating people.
If they're not a navy seal or they do some extreme shit.
Yeah,
John is fine.
We'll listen to Jockos a state walks the walk.
Also his name also fucking super smart guy.
Like he's not,
I mean he is definitely a meat head,
but he's the right kind of meat.
Smart meathead.
I mean,
you're a meathead.
I'm a meathead Brian.
You're kind of asking me what I am head.
I'm not amazing.
You are.
Pretend you're a little bit,
sometimes you go meet head,
like when you and him wrestle together,
then when you get smushed you decided,
I mean head brain from eight heading,
you drive an electric car.
I don't have the frame but I,
I have a,
I have a lot of enthusiasm.
He meatheads with celebrate that they got a scratch on their forehead from the
rough frame is not that bad.
Yeah.
Good Body B.
It's not that bad.
Like if you really got into lifting weights,
you could be Jack.
I've been doing Olympic lifting like lawn.
Really?
Yup.
At the offense.
Barbell club.
So fuck,
you got to have to,
I'd have to confirm it.
You want to show you something that makes you feel bad.
I explode off the line.
Get you some of that B and Soak that in.
Soak descent.
See you could get that.
I'm sorry it happened to your arm right now.
Hey Joe.
You know Brian,
I had a tattoo.
You know,
he has to get a tattoo.
We got,
remember we got 10 million downloads.
Yes.
Oh,
that's right.
Fighter and the kid tattoo.
Yeah,
that's going to be a good thing to have once fighter in the man goes,
this is back in the day when everything was cooking for me.
I'll just fucking that.
I'll just lift and then I'll get a little thicker.
I just can't put on weight because I don't try hard enough and I don't care.
I want to see my box just with you and Eddie Bravo.
Just you and Eddie.
Bravo.
God.
Just the pizzagate chronicles.
Everyone.
Oh,
what a beautiful sweep.
Did I tell you the Donaldson?
Ronda came and watched me spar and I go,
what am I doing wrong?
And he goes,
everything
here's,
everybody gave me a lesson.
It was growing,
but we're flying up the homie.
So starting me off boxing,
I,
he wouldn't talk to me.
He got mad.
I go my sparring and he goes,
I'm not talking to you about spark.
I can't have this conversation.
He got it.
He got really on the plant.
He goes,
oh,
I can't do this.
I can't cause I was mad and I was like,
I'm not my left.
And he's like,
I'm not going.
What the fuck?
Cause I sucked them in for a second.
Like I sucked him in.
He's like,
well,
if you wanted,
if you will,
what do you want to do it?
He goes,
what the fuck am I doing?
What am I doing?
I'm not talking to you about do you not have enough going on in your life that
you need to focus on sparring and Balis distracting himself with like tennis
lessons and all that.
She's shad lighting jokes,
no ship and he's out there hitting myths and I do it all.
You do it all do help.
Tired is this guy.
I'm going to change this topic now,
Tom,
nice take down the call,
running the pipe.
That's a good,
but it's going to take down.
Simple,
simple.
He's almost fucked to the simple
single legs slide on.
You guys.
Notice them out quietly.
Russians are just taking over.
They're not regular white people.
They're not.
They're just quietly taking shit over culture that that puts masculine power at
a premium.
Anthony Joshua would care to defer.
Hey Dude,
how about fucking personal?
Walked in the box and burn,
just walked in and was like,
shit,
that's cool.
Oh fucking just giant dude checking things out.
I'm here to mix things up.
You wants to train cause his girl ivy wants to train their,
you know,
just when he's doing things here in la.
Oh that's so that's going to be the Jimmy works at I think so young.
She's tanks going to working on a boxercise gym.
Well kind of.
I Conor Mcgregor,
we're talking to the wildcard.
I Dunno.
Maybe he doesn't want to deal with all the bullshit.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
Cause box number and you can the shut like for [inaudible] they shut it down.
I'll do that.
When I was in camp,
they'd literally shut the class that they organize stuff around.
Oh interesting.
I was talking to West Chatham about,
he was like,
he would work at it wildcard west,
but every time he be,
we're not somebody who would be like,
you want to spar,
you want to sparring.
And it's like that's the culture there.
Yeah.
That's tough.
When you just want to work out.
It's like,
and he doesn't want to say no,
and I told you this before Brian,
because Brian was like,
I just want to get put out of spoiler.
He went,
I want you to walk into wildcard west and he'd get all the spike in handle.
Myra Lopez will punch you in the Dick.
So we'll punch you.
The Sopa Barn is Mario dues.
He's,
he's budge.
But do I worry about that?
I worry about those guys that do that recreational sparring and then all of a
sudden one day like where are my keys?
It doesn't make sense in my hand can hit.
It doesn't make sense to me.
Why are you doing?
Are you getting paid?
He in the head.
I don't get it.
I talked to him about it when,
um,
he fought one of our friends from a 10th planet Jujitsu.
He's been boxing for a long time too.
I think it has been like,
legitimately he had an amateur boxing match with a buddy of mine.
I just,
Yep.
I get,
it's fun.
You've got to test yourself and maybe you know you're in TV,
so you've got to make sure you still have your main card,
stuff like that.
But there's other ways to do it.
I just,
Jujitsu is the best way to do it because you don't,
you don't,
you don't get the brain damage,
but a lot of guys don't like the damage to your neck and your knees and your
joints and your back.
I don't know.
There's,
that's a personality thing too.
I think Stryker's a lot of times have different personalities.
I'm talking about guys who do it.
Like the difference between a striker,
pure striker and a pure wrestler.
There's actually a personality difference.
I think sometimes maybe it's also like,
you know,
a lot of guys who could have been big time or would have really gotten big time
into striking.
They found Jujitsu first and they've got big time into Jujitsu.
It depends with that look,
I loved both of them and I love striking and I loved it all.
I loved Jujitsu.
I mean,
I think that the difference in striking clearly is that you can get hit and hurt
and you get hit a little bit in Jujitsu,
QED but each other and run into the shit.
Do you know what I would've done?
And I'm not being funny here.
If you put me in a time and I was like
say 1814 I'm not kidding with trade and last thing.
Are you kidding?
Yeah.
I tried it and run slang,
taekwondo,
all this up.
I would be,
I would be practicing an instrument.
I would be a great dancer and I would sing,
just want to get distracted by pussy and he would start doing stand up.
I don't think you would do that.
Be Maybe I had to be a fighter.
I think.
No,
cause I I knowing what I know now,
I don't have that now.
Dancing w you fucked up by not singing and dancing.
Look at me.
I would have been great dancing,
dancing,
singing.
I was singing it.
Something you can work at,
and I'm not talking about being it's white singer.
I'm not talking about being,
no,
you're wrong,
you're wrong.
You're completely wrong.
Yes,
some people have amazing instruments,
but you can become a very good singer just with training.
But believe me,
you can,
especially if you could translate into being good singer has to be a dick.
But I,
I did sing it when in theater school.
Like I got to a point where I could,
I wouldn't hurt your ears.
I mean it's not song.
Did you sing?
I don't know.
I sang all the musicals and stuff.
Gimme gimme a couple notes.
I'm like a,
I sang into the woods.
No mortgage giants saint a little bit.
No,
come on a little bit cause I'm it,
it'll move you to tears.
Come on.
I can't,
I can't just,
I picked you as a country western music inside of me.
I picture you're doing like a cover of like some Hank Williams Jr.
No Dude,
I don't sing country.
Don't like country new kids on the block.
No,
no.
Listen,
some people like have great voices,
but you gotta remember Justin Timberlake's been singing since he was a little
kid born with a lot of town though.
It's been saying since he was a little kid.
And toweling talent though talent,
but also like this is that I wish I could go wrong.
Bron James,
I don't know.
Hold on.
It's actually very different.
I'm sorry.
Yes there's talent,
but there's all,
there's timing and common,
but like singing and dancing is something that when you've been doing since a
little kid like that,
that the reason that he's so good is that's been trained into it.
He also has tenant though be he has talent.
A lot of people definitely have talent,
but I think what Brian is saying is that you can get better.
Oh,
for sure.
With coaching and I think that it's also a muscle,
isn't it?
Throat your throat to 100% of muscle,
so,
so you,
you can get to be 100% of us so that you can get very good and very powerful
with your voice.
I just know too many Broadway singers and dancers,
the amount of practice that they put in from early ages,
it's,
it's a very,
very physical products.
Like the opera is the same way and I agree.
You can practice being get better,
but don't you think a lot of those singers,
they're pinched,
learned from a very young age?
They were performers like they were good at seashore.
I mean,
look,
probably not for you.
And even if even if Michael Jackson helped him sing all his life,
he's not going to be a professional singer.
So my Brummie lessons,
Adele had my exam it up.
Well,
she's very special,
but she also was only singing.
She also makes money doing it,
but,
but some people are very,
very special.
But like,
um,
my grandfather,
when I did a musical and my grandfather taught me do a musical and I was 22 or
whatever,
and he said to me,
it was great.
It's a Sicilian from Brooklyn,
no nonsense.
He goes,
listen to me,
you're funny.
You made them all laugh with your antics.
You'll never going to make it living as a singer.
Don't sing.
Don't waste your time on this now I had only been singing for the year.
Like I said,
how about I show you fuck face,
and then you start singing in his face,
fucking son on la La,
la,
la.
Here's that fucking bullshit.
Logan interested,
not interested.
Don't let the little girls and girls will,
she's,
yeah,
she's the best thing in the movement or not to it.
It looks pretty good as high octane action.
That's what they just said.
Mel asked you this when he got jacked for Logan,
how many steroids did he do?
All of them.
Hey,
you know,
hey it muscle fitness,
this is muscle and fitness.
He goes,
you know,
when I got the Wolverine Role,
I knew I need to put on some muscle.
So I called up the one guy who knows about this and a rock sent me his Dietitian
and I got in his diet and I went to the boat and winstrol.
How's that work in grass fed beef?
Is it just pure red meat and testosterone or he's got a big frame.
I mean,
he's six [inaudible] six for a big guy.
He's a big guy for sure,
but I mean he got
that.
You don't get that kind of vascularity in your forties,
unless you're Brian Callum.
You know what?
There's a picture of him that's not even the best picture.
It's Christ photo shopped a little bit,
but oh,
I don't know about that.
I mean the veins and one that's a little Photoshop is a little photo shoot.
There's,
there's,
there's pictures of him legitimately in the gym.
Lifting weights.
Muscle is not as big there as he was in the other ones,
but that vast so,
and some movies he got bigger and not mad,
but that's probably as legit as it gets.
Really mad men.
Yeah.
There's some that with him lifting,
there's one of him dead lifting.
See if he could find Hugh Jackman dead lifting.
I think he's kind of,
um,
a comment on that is in the pool.
I'll get that some bullshit there.
That looks like here.
That normal deluxe,
one of them dead,
lifted,
jacked that we'll ring you them right there.
Yeah.
He's lifted in some real weight.
I mean that's the way to get bigger man.
You want to get bigger?
You've got to dead lift.
Yeah.
Della always say Joe,
is that what you always say?
Always you?
What's up son?
Hey,
good body wearing jean shorts while you're fucking ideas being a
multimillionaire.
That's what he breathes.
Daisy dukes.
That's a tough thing to pull off today as a guy.
Yeah.
I was off third street yesterday and just every girl had her ass cheeks out like
these short short shorts or in his bitches aren't playing ass or non like God
damn bitch bitches harm planning,
not planning.
They tried to sell that pussy white girls with flat rock gum,
just whatever.
Who can sing and dance that guy.
He changes the subject.
Oh,
sorry.
I want to go back to muscles.
All your boy Ben Saunders,
Saunders a Peter Sabato.
That's a good fight.
Biggest one 70 and the world's tallest six two and he's definitely not,
but he looked talking say Damien Maia is big.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh my God.
You want me to just find the 85 wow.
Yeah.
Damien is going to be in town soon.
We'll try to get them on the podcast.
That'd be great.
Yeah.
His English isn't phenomenal the best,
but it's good enough.
It's outside board doesn't be great and just it was good enough.
We'll cyborg.
You brought her in with her boyfriend,
right?
Yeah.
Did you see what Brian Stan did to a towering whittling when they were talking
about,
uh,
when?
When after he won,
um,
what's his name?
One fucking,
I'm,
I'm seeing ally Damien Maia and a prion.
Stan took a nap sack and put it on his back and then,
then Brian Santa Go,
Nah,
forget that.
And Aztec and he just jumped on his back of his,
this,
what's going to feel like it used to this and tell who at least holding them in
a suit.
It was,
we see what Tyron Woodley did.
He made a video of him preparing for the Damien Maia fight.
He put a backpack on and went through his entire workout with a backpack on.
Right.
That's great.
Yeah.
Do you,
what do you mean don't do random?
He said Jermaine Duran.
It'd be said she's not fighting.
Cyborg.
Cyborg is a cheater.
She's is,
she's a known cheater.
She said,
I can't trust her to not cheat,
cheated or hope so scared.
Defend the belt after just a little bit of a cop out.
It doesn't it?
Cause I mean when was the last time cyber got caught in 2012 here's tiring
working out with the backpack on.
It's funny.
That's where the fuck your backup.
That's when I really,
there's no weight and that it's just got some clothes.
He's just joking around.
Just not a good way to work.
I work out with a backpack on.
I have a specific backpack.
This design by this company called the outdoorsman that actually holds a weight
plate on it.
Oh yeah.
Look at Olympic barbell.
Please send me all this shit.
I'll send it to you.
But they have um,
uh,
a thing on it where it's six on the back,
actually have tool.
I'll give you one please.
And you put a weight plate on and it clamps down just like that's just like a
bar and I'll use the weighted vest.
It's not great.
Not as good.
You can get 90 pounds on this fucker.
Damn.
So I need it for the stairs to see if you could find one of those two.
How bad.
I fucked my uh,
knee up.
I fucked my knee up.
What?
I've been run so much,
it just hurts and I was running yesterday.
I text,
can we go,
hey man,
I'm putting a lot of miles and you know I'm doing like six miles a day.
Write in every day.
I'm going to put a lot of miles in man.
Like my knee hurts.
What do you do?
He Goes Ah,
if it takes like six hours,
cause he's probably killing,
shoot some beer in the face.
He was,
yeah he was,
he texts me back is uh yeah.
Induced from time to time.
I kind of just suck up and power through and that's all he does.
Oh cool man.
Here's what I'll do.
Sleeps four hours a night and never gets sick.
He's just a freak.
She's eaten moose meat every day too.
Well I don't think that hurts.
He eats bear three days a week.
He's just an animal.
I feel like that's really good for you.
I just need to lose out some way to from a run as much as I lose a little
weight.
I feel like this one thing that is legit about what cam is doing is not just his
mental toughness is undeniable.
His work ethic,
undeniable.
The fact that he's been running forever,
He eats wild game.
His shirts are so gay.
I keep telling him this,
you cannot cut your shirt down to this.
I know you live in Oregon,
but if you come to California and she got dressed like,
cause he was taking your mouth while you're on the bench.
He has,
he has the like the,
you know the skin.
Oh boy.
Like he cuts them like they like to see my canon was tits out the back.
I'm like,
Bro,
you do that here on promise,
you and your Dick in her mouth.
You can't go to cams.
Um,
go to camps,
Instagram stories and his boy like,
yeah,
bumping chests and they both had the same tea on the tee tank.
You'll love this.
Be Really,
yeah,
you can do a love the Instagram story.
That's right.
See if you can find pictures of him working out on it is,
but here I'll find it.
There's tons of pictures on his Instagram.
Stories are pretty ridiculous though.
He can,
if he listened,
let's stop wearing the cut the shit buddy.
Hey Bro,
you do that here in La and here we go in the mouth and it says it's meat so that
it's not a bad,
uh,
I mean he looks at every game,
man's Geranium,
every sure it's meat.
It's meat,
sir.
Do you know what that is?
Meets her is from,
it's a quote by John Mayer,
which is even more gay.
Uh,
John Mayer was on a,
um,
some sort of a radio show and they were asking them about what he eats.
He was in Montana and he's like,
well,
I have some friends and they cook wild game.
And he's like,
well,
how do you cook it?
He goes,
it's meets her,
you cook it,
you just,
you know,
he could get on a grill since he's the song bird of our generation.
So you guys watch your fucking mouth?
Not really anymore.
He's committee go kind of fell off,
came to get me started talking shit about girls.
You fucked like,
like Jessica Simpson and Shitty.
Did some interviews and he was like dishing and they lost a lot of respect
because he's the guy who bought his London.
Everybody wants to thinks he's just roll mill manager.
These guys.
It'd be good to my daughter.
You piece of shit.
Fuck.
Fuck you John.
Man.
He was so talented.
10th Planet Jiu Jitsu.
Ben Saunders ready to go down.
Dan Waiting at one 68,
six,
two bit of six to every bit of six ps.
One of the nicest guys on the planet.
All right,
dude.
Yeah,
I love Ben.
He's a fucking great guy.
Oh,
I can't wait for the main,
if he's got a nasty fucking guard too,
man.
Nasty guard.
If you don't know what you're doing and Ben Saunders wraps you up,
he's going to put you,
is going to put you in some bad positions.
Let's see what Peter said.
Bought.
I could do about that.
Darcy,
what is that Eddie Bravo doing is he's,
he's in town.
He's in Singapore.
He was doing a super camp.
It was over there,
a teaching Jujitsu and um,
then he was there for the one fc event,
which a fucking Ben aspirins still undefeated now.
16.
And,
oh Jesus Christ.
Bring him over here please.
While you still can fight,
you think he said,
hey,
you signed a fucking soccer.
What's a gold car?
Go can cycle cotton socks will being great.
Six years ago,
fucking signed been ass grin out dairy.
Oh,
come on Bro.
I'm still talking about Cole Khan.
Saki right now.
Son.
Go con is a fucking savage now.
He's a super source voids.
Tossum a grappler.
Yeah.
That's going to have to kick,
kick,
kick out.
Yeah.
I was going to happen.
Hopefully.
It's so weird signing.
Hopefully he'll have a uh,
a guy's willing to stand with black for Ben.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
he cracked.
Signed the overhead.
But you won't sign fucking Ben Aspirin.
Come on.
Ben Asked Karen and Dana White have a real thing debt and Ben asking and talk to
a bunch of shit about Dana White.
How many years ago?
Come on.
Trusted.
You're talking,
you're preaching to the choir.
If it was me,
I would already signed him.
I would have them.
You got,
Dan is here.
He calls Dan.
He don't want to listen to me.
I look,
it's the same thing about me telling you to write jokes.
I don't do it.
It's fuck you.
I write jokes.
Fuck.
Tell him that's my nerve.
Don't say that in pots.
A trigger.
Like I'll,
I'll have an argument now.
My cars,
I'm driving like,
hey fuck,
ah,
you put
Ben at the welterweight division.
He's going to wrestle his way to the championship and they don't want,
I love it.
I want to see him versus Damien Maia Yas.
Oh,
or you don't work or you have something to say for Ben took,
yeah,
I've tried training partly down to trading partners.
Yeah,
but that's a problem.
But the problem with Woodley is woolly can put you on the fucking planet.
Pluto was one punch.
He's so,
yeah,
I get you a little stumbly Pluto one puck kind of fucking stumbled through that
one.
Highly always say put you on Pluto was trying to come up with a better word.
Damien Maia has a very hard time taking Woodley down.
Well,
how do you think that fight goes down?
It's a hard fight for Damien.
Very hard fight because Damien Woodley is ruthlessly powerful on his feet.
His fucking striking is so scary.
Think about what he did to Wonderboy.
Two fights in a row.
Yeah.
Uh,
two fights in a row.
One fight,
two fights.
That second fight was punk shit.
He heard them bad though.
Still 30 seconds in the fifth round,
but still he can do that.
He can hurt you.
It's always a liability and he's hurting Wonderboy.
Who's one of the best strikers literally ever in the 170 pound division.
True.
Tyron Woodley can hurt anybody.
He's got sucked.
Nobody did it.
Robbie Lawler one punch.
Paul,
here's the problem.
Here's the problem.
Well not the prime,
but here's what if Damien Maia stymied and engage in that,
he's going to jump to garden half guard.
That's where it gets tricky in a try.
But he's 39 years old and he's going to try to do,
I don't know about way big.
Oh,
he's a,
he's way taller,
taller,
but Tyron is a fucking tank.
He's all muscle.
Yeah,
but you,
but you get Damien Maia in a deep half guard.
I don't care who you are.
You don't have some trouble.
Yeah.
But you're going to be taking shots on the way in.
Oh No.
I th I think,
uh,
Woodley's the roughest matchup for Damien Maia to get a belt.
But yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
There couldn't be a worst matchup for him,
but I like it.
I like it because it's interesting.
But man,
I wish Damien had a shot at this like a few years ago.
So Bob has got some good striking,
he's got a great chap,
watch this,
he's doing these undercuts and all this kind of stuff is good fighter.
Very good striker first dean lister in his corner.
Yeah,
he is.
Definitely is dean lister and Peter Bought Sabattus called.
Yep.
Interesting.
Where is he this jab as you'll see him.
Boom,
boom.
Pretty sure Ben has gotten a long ass reach man and he likes to throw a lot of
those front kicks to the body,
dude.
How Bouts Cowboy
Robbie Lawler.
That's crazy.
So I think Ben,
I mean Ben can stand with people for sure,
but I think Ben's best chance is if you can get this fight to the ground.
Yeah.
Cause he,
I think Ben in the clinic was really Japanese.
I Love Ben in the plum.
Yeah,
no,
he's got a great poem.
He had a great plan.
What's these?
He's long.
They can't really get them to do so much bigger than them.
What's the plum?
The Thai clinch.
Oh.
Um,
uh,
Sabato has been lightened them up,
but that jab man,
that's a nice step in jab swift.
Just going underneath to,
he's doing an upper cuts and I think it's hard time sometimes when south paws
fight other south paws too,
that like,
Ooh,
yeah,
yeah.
It's a bit of a shit show.
Yeah.
It's guys facing looks just like he's Ben's eyes pretty fucked up from that.
Keeps getting caught,
man.
Yeah.
Working.
Ben's was trying to close the distance.
Oh,
you got click that left hand.
It's the same.
They right clip
and it's taken a lot of punishing.
Smooth.
Okay.
But he's trying to get time but he's trying to get that clinch in Sabata.
Okay,
let's see if he can do anything.
Okay.
Here we go.
Much smarter bottle.
Just let them stand out.
A lot of fucked up wrapped up here.
He's got a mission control here.
This is what Ben needs is not good.
This is not good for us about it.
And Ben's got these crazy long ass legs.
Gonna get that left leg out.
Watch.
Watch him pop that left leg out.
He's also Staccato.
Sabata is trying to ease his uh,
his right knee forward every time Ben moves his leg,
but it's going to pop up over the top.
Now Subodh is not in a good place.
This is not good.
He's trying to put tea in danger of getting caught with hear submissions.
So first of all,
his left arm was completely trapped in his right arm is on the mat,
which is the wrong place for it.
Cause his right arm should be on the chest right now because Ben's going to put
him in the dead orchard,
which means both legs trapped in a triangle or both arms rather trapped in a
triangle.
How much time is left though?
Not much pulled the clock.
It's probably 10 10 seconds.
Yeah.
But also remember Ben's recovering right now.
It's a great move by Ben.
Terrible move by homeboy to let him go to fly farm down to the ground.
Yeah.
I don't know why he did that.
I think he thought he can hammer them out.
Okay.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So what we were talking about non fight related,
we were just talking about something super important.
Um,
hold on.
We were talking about Tyron Woodley,
dangerous.
He was a singer.
Jermaine Cyborg.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I think takes a lot too much.
You do too much hate.
You know,
she do you,
I love that.
Change your physiology.
Don't you think that,
I mean,
no more than anybody else has.
Right.
You're talking about the woman has done that?
I don't,
I mean if we're talking about steroid use that she got caught with 2012,
I mean how many people have been caught with a steroid?
I think she takes out an unfair Bronto look at that straight.
Um,
I don't know.
It is what it is.
So let's see.
What do you do with that 145 pound division?
You just don't give Cyborg a fight.
No.
I think,
uh,
you vacate.
If Germain de Randamie does not want to fight Cyborg,
but she said,
and you are allowing Cyborg to fight and she won't fight her.
You,
uh,
first of all,
you got to give Cyborg.
I mean you got to give her a fight,
right?
Isn't she fighting cat?
But what cat and her both want it,
but they,
for whatever reason,
they want to announce the fight on the Anaheim card.
Why won't they announce it?
I have no idea to talk to your boy.
Hmm.
Well who knows what's going on.
You'd have to talk to Kat cause cat just came out hard against Reebok.
Well,
we'll see that the,
I saw that.
But the thing is,
is a cat,
cat,
cat wants to fight Cyborg once the fight,
but something,
there's some seems to be some sort of hiccup.
I'm not sure why know what it is.
But also,
you know,
with,
sideboards going on social media,
you know,
and it's good.
She's voice in a pinch.
She's unhappy,
but it's relentless.
It's every day.
I don't know if they want that as their champ.
So you want the fight and you won't be the champ now,
but the UFC is going,
hold up.
She,
she's already,
you know,
yelling.
Now what is she saying every day she's saying gimme a fight.
Oh,
Ben Saunders with a stiff jab.
She's literally saying,
I don't understand.
Give me a fight.
Let me fight Megan Anderson,
who's,
you know,
champion and Victor,
let me fight cat.
Let me fight somebody.
Do something.
Well,
I could see her argument.
That makes sense.
She wants a fight.
And Megan,
Hannah,
she wants a fighter.
I think that's a good fight.
The best fight can make,
can just go.
It really doesn't make sense.
Well,
cats and gotten was a name in the UFC and Megan and Sean doesn't have a name in
the UFC yet.
But yeah,
I agree with you.
That's a good fight.
And Megan Anderson's a big girl,
big girl,
and very talented,
very talented.
Great fight.
She's legit.
Hunter.
Oh,
Ben got rocked.
Ah.
Oh God.
Oh Jesus.
Tough for band,
man.
He's taken a lot of punishment in this fight.
Jesus.
Fuck.
He's tough though.
It's tough.
Tough,
tough as shit.
My God,
he's just autos.
Get that crazy.
So bottle.
I can calculate that like sort of Jab,
Jab,
jab to amazing.
It's been very smart and calculated.
Not Rushing,
taking punishment here.
There was busted up,
man.
He's busted up.
What a tough fucking taking punishment keeps coming.
He's trying,
he's trying to go with them to men.
That Anaheim card has John in DC though too.
You can't wait for that.
Well,
and I think there's another big fight on that card too,
right?
There's this,
who is it?
It just got announced in it.
Young Jamie.
What does that,
uh,
what's,
what's the current state of the Anaheim quiz show?
No,
I don't do cyber cat cyborg verse that.
Uh,
Megan Anderson.
Oh my God.
They should stop.
Stop,
stop.
Please stop.
Please.
Stop.
That's it.
That's good.
Stop.
It's good.
It should stop as a terrible fight
with Peter.
So Botha.
Hey Man.
He's a tough guy,
but that's a legit stoppage.
He got hurt.
That's fair.
He was taking a lot of management.
Piercer bottle look good.
You'll see two at 14 okay.
Daniel Cormier and Jon Jones.
What else do we got here?
Oh,
this isn't the main,
I mean,
this is just Suzanne so far.
Oh,
do,
oh Troy and Andrew feely.
Touchy.
Sterling Sterling.
Hennen brow.
That's a fun one.
I mean,
these aren't any needle movers,
but that boy,
there's still going to fill the cart up.
Oh,
it's out Jared borough.
That's a big step up for aljamain sterling.
Huge step on them.
They're banking on and kind of being over the hill.
I think he fed them route 15 he's ranked number 15 is he?
God Damn,
he's lost his last featherweight.
How old is he?
It's featherweight now,
right?
Remember we bought 35,
but still 15.
Fuck son.
Did you hear that?
Uh,
uh,
what's her face?
Um,
tested positive.
What the fuck's her name?
Um,
uh,
in Dallas.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I saw that it was test Usada.
she uh,
she had a elevated epitestosterone ratio.
Who is this?
What the fuck?
What
the Hell's her name?
Jeremy.
Yeah,
but under Usada rules she wouldn't have tested positive.
So tons of the Dallas Commission.
Casey.
Yeah.
Cortney Casey.
Casey.
There you go.
That's what it is.
That's what sucks is she,
you know her,
her when is overturned?
She's fine.
5,000,
but under,
you sought a rules.
She'd pass the test burner.
Dallas Commission like NASA and not up in here.
Under you side.
A rural,
she passed the test.
How's that work?
I have no idea.
But she has an elevated epitestosterone to testosterone ratio,
right?
Yeah.
Before Dallas though.
But under Usada regulation she did it.
That's weird.
But Dallas commissions when who overturned it?
Cause that's the commission and that weird.
Well,
I mean it makes you think like,
why doesn't you sought to have more stringent testing than doubt?
I don't understand why they have different standards like Olympics one to one I
think,
or two to one.
Some are four to 101 case he picked up the biggest wham blah blah blah.
You S Usada the official antidoping agency has yet to announce if they will be
taking any action.
Oh,
so Dallas is only suspended her for a short amount of time.
Now the only suspend her for 90 days.
We have not been informed by you side of anything regarding potential
anti-doping policy violation for Cortney Casey,
no positive tests,
no suspicion of anything now or in the past who saw it as not been in contact
about anything.
So scroll up to the top of this article.
So what happened here then?
Suspended for three months.
See that's what's weird because suspending her for three months through Dallas,
if,
if you get suspended through Usada it's two years.
Yeah,
right.
Isn't it two years?
But I mean most of the commissions they listened,
they all follow the same rules,
but she's just suspended in Dallas.
Yeah.
Joe Daddy.
But yeah.
Interesting.
It's weird.
The,
all the,
the,
you know,
four to one.
What I think Olympics two to one just depends on commission.
But with you Sadik cause you saw it as an employee of the UFC.
Remember you saw it as an outsource sub contracted employee.
The UFC.
Yeah.
But how does you saw to not catch it?
That's what I don't understand.
I don't,
they test the samples as well.
Wasn't it random?
They don't test everyone,
do they?
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't think they don't test every fighter on the card.
I I,
but Dallas does.
Dallas did random.
She was one of the random ones.
Now what causes someone to have an elevated epitestosterone range?
Like there's a bunch.
There's a bunch of wasted.
Yeah.
Trip those.
But a lot of it is like taking some sort of external testosterone.
It'd be,
yeah.
Peter Soboba TKL fight too and looking good.
Look at that world jacket.
Look at that handsome bastards.
You better come.
Correct.
In England,
man.
There's a handsome did.
He's very good looking man.
He's got a pocket square.
Of course he does it right.
Yes,
there it is.
Can I reach you style.
Oh,
this powerful dean lister thicker.
Thicker than a musketeer.
He is so thick and he rolls a jock all the time.
They're a training partner.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well couns out of the room was talk shit about them.
Hey guys,
come on.
Seriously.
So about that joke writing.
He's such a care.
That's a trigger for him.
It's fine.
I voided can.
I don't want to do,
can't help it.
It's like I wanted to poke.
It's a soft spot.
It's the only soft spot you'll see him right there.
I just want to go,
I avoid it.
And then to overcome state for it for the next week and talk about how much
riding he's doing.
I'm like,
do I never say you did it?
You don't tell Joe this.
Not me talking about his boxing.
What's right.
It's doing sparring.
Dub David also tough guy.
Okay.
I know we're just talking shit.
But Doug Davidoff can fight.
He can fight and he's a good friend of mine.
She's like John Joseph.
Joseph tight,
we're tight.
That's a good looking shack.
Tan Hardee's wearing what's up with that third button?
The English have to come.
Correct,
man.
I love when your boy Guy Ritchie broke it down on the seat.
I said,
fucking educate this man guy,
which he's a bad motherfucker.
He really,
is he a black belt?
Yeah.
He's a hands off for awhile.
Henzel Gracie doesn't give out any bullshit black belts.
It broke my heart is here and that and then hearing his movie bombed.
Did it bomb?
Yeah,
a little bit.
Did you watch it?
You didn't see?
No,
I didn't see it.
I'm just saying that's what the box office,
I don't know if it sucks.
I just know it didn't do well at the box office,
which doesn't mean it bombed as far as money making.
It's a tough sell man.
Oh,
movies,
King Arthur movie with a modern twist to,
yeah,
like I know,
but if anyone I,
you know,
I feel like they didn't know that Guy Ritchie was that big of a part of it.
I feel like that would have sold it more cause then once I found out he was
doing it,
I was like,
Oh,
I'm definitely an,
now they're talking about Jimmy man and fighting a boxing match with David.
Hey,
he's trying to organize some sort of a boxing match.
I don't get it.
Yeah.
Well I would like to see because manawat he's such a fucking Badass striker.
If he wants to be that bad ass tracker,
please welcome go Ka Saki.
That's a fight.
The fight she'd be,
man was going to show up with a fucking single in on
six wrestling.
She's fucking the fucking air covers on why?
Because your fingers Tazy wants to wrestle on.
It doesn't have to be down.
Three point stance on a strike with a Turkish Tyson.
Have you ever seen work outside?
I never seen him pull up a go con highlight reel and powerful dad gut prepare to
watch a mother fucker knock people into another dementia.
We do that.
I want to ask you,
the UFC just signed them be lightening hands.
I want to see it.
I want to ask you really quickly.
If I put moose meat and elk and you had an a on a plate,
could you tell the difference?
It depends on how it's prepared.
They're very similar.
Outlook has a little bit more flavor to it.
See if you can get,
is this a highlight reel?
It's a highlight reel.
His fucking hand combinations are ruthless and my God.
Oh Dude,
you don't even know him.
He's one of the best kick boxers of all time.
Well,
Tyrone Spong has a broken leg.
Oh my God.
Look at it from Saki.
Oh Dude.
Come on son.
Go Con Saki light motherfuckers though.
Oh No,
but that love to know,
Dude.
He has an educated lefthand look to his body's nothing to write home about the
show.
Just a stocky fella.
Savage.
He's a fucking straight that's over him,
son.
We'll kick.
What the fuck that was over.
And by the way,
how much does he weigh?
How big is he?
He's a for two oh five or he's going to fight two oh five that's him against
[inaudible].
He fought Spong and checked his leg and spawns leg snapped in half like Anderson
Silva was Jesus Christ.
How is his,
uh,
tell him to get that mask off?
That shit doesn't work because they're bad for you.
And that's how these people,
you know what these people believe in those fucking masks.
Mad silly how,
um,
his,
his wrestling go.
Saki.
No idea.
Terrible.
Awful
is kickboxing is off.
The record is an MMA.
Oh,
his hair.
And he got submitted.
Oh,
look at this.
Ooh,
there's sun came correct though with the fashion
human rooster.
The human rooster goes down.
That left hand has come off the charts.
Oh,
look at him just kicking like this.
Imagine those with four ounce gloves.
Wash this combination,
man.
Hey,
look at this.
He's,
come on son.
He's going to get taken down.
Look at this.
They're not going to give them wrestlers.
Be Dude,
look at this fucking common nation.
They're going to make an exception.
And this is Daniel Geeta.
He's fighting title my best heavyweights in the fight.
This dude with a blonde.
Well,
how do you stay?
How do you strike with them?
Then if you're UFC guy,
that's ridiculous.
I don't know.
You got to find out whether or not you can.
It's a different game.
I'll tell you this right now.
I don't want to be Jimmy Manawat.
These curls.
Well,
who knows if they're going to give him Jenny.
Man,
he works.
The Jimi Manuwa is like top three in the world right now at heavyweight though.
It's fucking,
we need something.
That's how we,
okay,
well I just feel like someone,
they're going to have put him in there with someone that's a good fighter,
but this is just striking.
This is a big test though.
I mean to have him come into the UFC,
it's a big signing.
It's a big deal for a guy like me.
I mean my Dick is hard as a rock right now.
I'm very excited about this.
I promise you God.
That's some,
I feel like that's a Bella Torah move.
Like,
yeah,
it does suck out of here.
He get his hands now.
Okay,
he's going to put hands on people.
No,
he's not.
Oh,
I'll take a high school wrestler and he's going to mop on the fucking floor.
Give them a high school wrestler,
give him money.
I want to give him somebody who lost a bet who has to go in there and stare and
it has a little bit of grudge and the UFC is like,
you're going to have to do this one for someone who's just like,
ah,
questionable judgment.
Someone who makes a lot of mistakes in their lives,
they're a good striker strike.
Here's his Wilcon terrifying.
Well,
someone wants approval one own welcoming them to the,
you have shoot,
show him what a real striker.
But it might be the Meinhof phenomenon too though.
Like,
uh,
what's his name?
Melvin mine off man.
It was just like some sort of a scientific principles.
Mine.
Sorry about the wind huff,
but he was so scary and devastating.
Man.
You're talking 10 years ago.
I'm saying though he didn't,
after the law I thing Melvin Melvin was a monster,
but Melvin had so many knock out losses like that.
His,
he really can't take a shot anymore,
unfortunately.
He just kept k out again.
Yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
I mean you just get head kicked again and Beltre we,
they're just strong jacket.
Kenny,
Jack to kill,
killing the game.
Did you guys sell out of those or what did we ever did we ever did?
Do you guys,
when you sell things,
if you sell a lot of them,
do you bring them back?
If they're good,
we always bring them back.
We got our summer collection about the drug.
What do we got?
Tees,
tanks,
teas and tanks.
Tasing tanks,
tees,
tanks,
dad hats.
Sp Saki.
Oh Man.
OSP.
We'll take him down and von flue the fuck out of him.
Correct.
That's what I want to see Ya.
It's just he shouldn't fight a top 10 guy right away to think that's silly.
I mean,
I don't know what kind of experience he hasn't training.
Let's see him pick it up.
We'll hit hilarious cm punk.
He's a lot bigger than cm punk hate.
It's the Wild Boston days.
But here is the wild west and you do and watch the video would be all about cm
punk training.
They just,
they cause the,
the owners don't what they're doing.
So she put all their eggs and see on punks basket.
Then he gets fucking axe kick to the skull and cracked his face and half.
That's what would happen.
He gets put on,
put on blast and he's going to fight again in the UFC as he,
uh,
yeah,
he could easily,
he is for sure with this,
with this regime.
Yeah.
Look at the,
UFC is in a weird position right now.
Connor is not fighting in the UFC right now.
I mean,
he's on hold for this.
Floyd Mayweather fight.
Ronda is completely out of the picture.
Mighty mouse doesn't want to fight.
Tj.
Cody is hurt like boy named the biggest fight of the year.
Joe,
it's been a rough year.
DC John Deasy Johnson would be the biggest,
the biggest fan.
I'm saying so far,
so far it really hasn't been any bangers.
What's been his do?
But what is the big that the steep bay one,
but the numbers aren't crazy.
I'm saying like a needle.
What were the numbers on that?
Can you bring that up Jamie?
I know it wasn't like ground shaking.
You know what's crazy?
I was watching Spencer broke yesterday.
I went,
Holy Shit.
Boxing this year is better than UFC for the first time.
It allows a pick fight.
But Boston in general this year has been killing it.
Oh yeah.
And they're making the matchups.
Everyone wants to see overlap.
Ward is next week.
That's next week.
Next week.
The second Jesus.
That's,
yeah,
right.
I know it's two weeks.
Two weeks,
two weeks.
Oh,
two weeks,
right.
It a second Cov lab.
It's the same weekend as the Aldo fight,
right?
No,
it's after that.
So week after that,
I said,
cause I'm,
I'm in Australia.
We've got to get back.
I made sure I fucking,
I don't want to miss that.
Nice.
350,000 pay per view buys.
That is not that bad.
So it gives me sir,
triple g got 150 for paying your bills.
Triple G.
I know,
but isn't that crazy?
Not really.
He barely speaks English,
but he's such a phenomenal box.
Yeah,
I know.
But Canelo Chavez got over a million paper.
Canelo doesn't speak English at all.
He can't a little,
but he likes to stick to his native tongue.
I'm just saying,
I'll just say Steve Bay doe sit like that card was a bang.
He likes to stick to his native tongue.
I would jack off certain things you say real sexual flare,
like sexual innuendo in there.
I don't know to soaring blackbuck I'll be a natural funny guy.
Brian callow.
Tell us about your tour dates.
Aren't you sold showing Ryan date and it just did a,
we just add x show in Sydney.
Holy Shit.
You're sold out in Australia.
Brian,
you saw it and I talk about being
June 8th ninth and 10th you fuckers Joe.
All I'm saying is 350,000 bytes for that man.
Do it.
But that card was,
so that was the best card to the gear.
Live gate record for the UFC events.
The American Airlines Center,
2.6 million,
19,000 fans interest too in 50,000 for that.
It's crazy to me,
man.
That's such a fun card.
Yeah,
but it's just when this weird time where people are,
you know,
how old do you think is this going to do the versus a 50,000 I'd say Joseph
verse a Holloway in America,
uh,
about 27 buys.
Gary,
you,
that's crazy though.
That's the world we're in right now.
Ontario.
I think it talks about mismanagement by the UFC.
I think that what you said about,
it's not frank care giving that young guy to Frankie Edgar,
that's a different thing now that's a different thing.
You're young.
Yeah.
It's just you go through phases in fighting like box right now it's killing it
and they have all these stars ready to compete.
You can see right now in that,
after the fact,
if [inaudible] did to Frankie Edgar what he did to Bj Penn,
you've got a giant superstar in Mexico.
Let's be fair though,
Joe.
Yeah.
Year fighting.
Bj Penn is completely different than the know you're fighting Frankie egg.
Oh,
100% like I love Bj Penn more than a lot of people.
100% he had no business fighting a year.
That was a shitty fight to do to budget.
We found out that he had no business.
He thought that he did.
Did we thought he was going to be able to do something.
That's crazy.
Well and then when like,
yeah,
you're Frankie,
but remember the desire asked for Frankie.
Yeah,
but you don't just cause he asked for is it timeless father time sense though.
It was timeless for Randy coture.
Well,
until Machita said is it timeless?
How's that to flying front kick coffee shop.
It's free the night before.
I'm sorry.
Volcanoes demeanor me sit Meesha Tsykunov two guys definitely getting stopped at
Tsa.
Your passport's from what?
Saw it got that name from Dagestan or something or where the fuck they're from
but that those names confused the shit on the tar tar steps there from those.
That's what I'm saying Bro.
You look at light heavyweight like suits and stuff from Toronto fighting a
Toronto.
God speaks really good English too,
by the way and he's a fucking sick grappler.
Puts the squeeze on people.
Number five verse number seven.
If if,
if number seven,
Nisha becomes fucking champion of the world.
If you think through it,
50,000 paper you buys were bad.
You still have to get real.
It's real nasty.
Mean she takes the light heavyweight champion.
Yep.
No,
no different meters.
You put on some weight.
He's a Russian,
but goddammit and this guy,
it's a true international sport guys,
Volk cotton,
all his demeanor.
He's the underdog.
Number five rank.
How did Austin mere become number five ranked?
Because cheeto fingers like yeah,
let's do it.
Is that real?
And he's also a wizard.
Wait a minute.
Cause light heavyweight division is it,
you know,
chances chest,
I want to say Austin mirrors only had a couple of fights in the UFC.
How many fights is always knew me or had an EOC,
young Jamie,
not a ton and definitely didn't beat a lot of topics.
We had a good fight with Osp,
but I believe he lost lost that fight.
So many fights.
Is those Demir had he beat Osb and a split decision?
You one.
Interesting.
So in beating Osp became number five in one fight.
God Dog,
they are thirsty for people.
Shogun is number four.
Whoa.
It's getting rough.
Wow,
that's crazy.
They can't rank Jon Jones,
even though John John's going to fight for the title because he's
right now.
Yeah,
Dude.
How about [inaudible] it going?
Still have an agreed on it on.
Uh Oh.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
Oh Shit.
Why don't you sell John Holly?
Sure.
Jon Jones,
he gets on the mic and calls out.
Call out little nog.
Oh,
was Daumier.
Damn owes to mirror.
I've been fucking talking about him since the eighties I guess he's number one
now.
Number one,
Alexander.
We're going to have to take a step back.
Listen,
he's not hurt,
so we're going to cancel this fight and we're going to move.
The main event was demeanor Ozdemir and it's the highlight of that man.
So it looks like me.
She was trying to close the gap and he just got lit up.
Let's check this out then up by the wizard wizard quick k.
Oh man.
It looks like a guy.
I played dungeons and dragons,
so vocab for cancer exclusively mob wizardry.
He's backing him up.
He's getting lit.
The fire lit up.
Boom.
Hit him right behind the air.
Short Punch like that.
Right behind the old tram.
Wow.
That's all it takes.
That's the best light heavyweight in the world.
You fucked.
That is crazy.
Know he's number one in the world.
That is not crazy.
You calm down.
That is a crazy one.
Punch knockout,
man.
If I ever have to knock somebody out and they're in my house,
I'll hit him right there.
And you said I'm number four,
Dan.
I'm never fucking four now in your crazy though.
Behind here.
You go out,
Huh?
Yeah.
Dude,
I can't wait to see him.
Verse John.
June doesn't tell you.
A lot of guys get hit behind the ear to get hip on in the year,
sliding to the side like that.
Mom does nothing where he was just getting bombed on.
It was like,
fuck boom.
That's crazy.
Why is the best?
Oh my God.
We're both those Tamir fans fighter and the kid we are fucking huge is trained
for putting some time,
long time,
dude.
Corey Anderson just fight.
Corey Anderson fought.
Who did he just fight?
So he beat Homeboy,
uh,
Brunson and then lots of Jimmy model.
It's got some nipples on him.
That's all I know.
We'll fucked him up man.
Fuck him up.
Mannerable lit him up.
No Brunson Save.
You pulled that up.
Pull up the Jimmy Manawat.
Kao is man.
What an African name and see from Africa originally from England,
but I'm sure African nice here and black.
You know Jimmy didn't even start fighting until he was like 28 years old and he
has first professional boxing match three months after he started training.
What?
Yup.
So I still have a chance.
Yes.
No,
that's the twice at 28 biologically look at my face.
No.
All right.
Blah,
blah blah.
The shitting on Brian continues.
Everybody had a lies.
I don't like the law.
Jimmy.
Jimmy,
Jimmy man was a fricking monster.
He's fun to watch,
but anytime he's faced a tough test,
he's never passed it.
Well clover,
he's gonna fight 'em work and he's not actually,
it doesn't have fight,
but supposed to fight the gun case.
He got k owed by rumble,
which everybody does.
Well,
it's such a bomber that rumble gonna retire.
Yeah,
he's out.
It's crazy.
Do we know what he's doing for the rams?
Just,
I don't know if he's doing,
he's doing something with the weed is a weed business and he corrected me cause
I went,
how the hell is he doing CBD stuff with the Rams?
And he reached out to was like,
Yo,
they're not connected full.
Well I'm doing something with the rams offs in sports and I'm doing CBD medical
marijuana over here.
They're not intertwined,
asshole.
My bad,
my bad,
my bad.
It's crazy because he's arguably one of the most talented guys in the history of
the division and he gets out on top.
But listen,
that's the way to get out and what his explanation for it was.
Perfect.
Look,
I'm tired of wrestling with dudes.
I'm tired of getting hit.
He said I never enjoyed fighting.
I was just good at it.
I don't want to do this.
That's fair.
A I can freehand good for him to hell yeah.
Good for him.
What do you do?
Stick around and there's three of you up there.
You're just gonna.
You're gonna keep fighting.
Glover fucking Gustafson and Jon Jones and now my boy fucking Meesha.
Yeah.
No,
no.
It's all council,
Campos demeanor.
That's all can.
That is such a crazy stoppage that he catches him behind the ear like that
sliding away to me,
man along.
You Better Watch your fucking ps and qs.
Watch it.
Jimmy.
Jimmy Vulcan.
But let me tell you something.
Jimmy man was not going to run at you like that.
This is crazy me.
She's coming for look at this.
Think that's so weird.
That's so interesting.
I'll cold good time to do it too.
Right,
and I'll be in a fight where you're crazy.
Look at this bow.
It shuts off.
She'll be back.
I just never seen anything like this.
Do you know?
This is a big fight for me.
She too,
because Misha was almost out of the UFC.
I had rough negotiations.
They had rough negotiations and then he gets starched like that in 10 seconds.
How many seconds was that?
If you had to guess?
About six 12 hmm?
What are they saying?
What was it?
12 preying on them on a tray.
I mean have the things to eat that Switzerland,
Switzerland,
Switzerland is,
he can be the best light heavyweight in the world happened with the Switzerland.
Yeah,
you can.
Okay.
Here's coriander.
So that's a good fight.
It's true.
Volkov vocal out just beat a fucking Roy Nelson Mandela to,
to actually when Manoa knocked out Cory,
I'm sorry.
Knocked him out with one punch.
The real impressive Kayah was manageable versus Osp Mattawa lit OSP up like he
was a fucking evergreen tree in Times Square.
For sure.
Just bet.
Bet.
You got to see those fluid combination has Korean it handsome.
He's got nippled up.
He's nippled up guys.
Cory Anderson Black on black crime here.
He just catches him on their first round.
You don't at all,
man.
I'm so what do you see when you see people equal rights?
It's a huge hobby of mine,
so I don't,
okay,
so how
about the cops come some,
some guy from Africa robs you.
Yeah.
How do you describe jumping in by describing
what color?
The carpet even then I'm furious.
I describe him as a man was small calves in a high belly button.
That's all I say.
Hi Billy Button.
I saw doing line,
I was buying some chicken the other day,
no racism.
And uh,
as I was going to buy some chicken,
because I'm a white guy,
I like chicken too.
There was this guy in line that could not be anything but black just by like,
I could like send you a picture.
His ass was so ridiculous.
It was like this guy was fat too.
It wasn't like an athlete,
but he's asking,
he met up his back.
He had like a belly and his upper body looked normal,
but his ass was literally like,
he was stealing basketball.
This guy put a basketball in each.
Celebrate that.
I call that the ostrich effect.
I'll see some Instagram girls,
same way.
Instagram girls.
A lot of those bitches of fake ass.
If they're black,
you never know man.
Just black girls with fake.
Yeah.
If the white girl with a black cast and you know it's a,
it's a black girl,
she'll,
she'll get you.
Well the white girls that have those acids that are fake,
the problem is they don't have fake thighs.
That's right.
So they have these two pages look like popsicles,
like those Kim Kardashian pictures.
You saw this kid event wondering if those are real sir.
Yes,
and so she did get a fake ass here.
100% here's the way in this room would have fun.
Here's what happened.
What she usually does is bring fake Paparazzi with her places.
They take these fake candid photos and they airbrushed the shit out of him.
They Photoshop them,
they make everything look beautiful.
But when she was in Mexico,
she got jacked by Real Paparazzi to Mexia.
I don't give a fuck.
They were hiding in the bushes and they did some real Paparazzi pictures.
Yeah,
that it's not a good look.
I was hearing about Paul.
Oh,
it's horrible because they're eating tamales,
big lumpy,
dumpy thing and then the legs of these little skinny things.
They're not doing any,
well,
she's not,
she's not an athlete.
Whereas if you look like,
look at Serina Williams,
that's what I'm say.
Fuck
giant Alpha black female.
I do it in a sort of a talking group with her.
I was looking at her arms.
She had this very nice little dress and I was looking at her.
Beautiful.
Did she just,
I literally had to reach out to one point and grab her spine.
She's a spazz dude I was backstage with before she was at the Miami.
Back that up just a hair young Jamie asks is all,
it's 100% muscle meat.
Watch this.
Watch this Kale a little bit.
Just a wee bit earlier at washes.
I don't remember this bank.
Crazy hub and one is,
come on man.
I know it's so accurate.
Yeah.
She's a stud athlete and if you look at her ass,
her ass is ridiculous.
As tennis player.
Best female tennis players say ridonculous ridonculous Oculus,
but her legs are too.
Yeah,
like her legs fit her ass horse power.
I feel like everyone here including James,
a little light in the ass for her include myself.
Well she likes but she likes regular white guy.
Have you seen her man?
Her mission?
Her man looks like she's marrying a guy who looks like you know he'll dress it
looks like in here.
What's that?
Alexis Ohanian.
She's marrying him.
She's pregnant.
She's pregnant with his baby.
Well,
that's ridiculous.
She knows she fucks him with a strap on.
I know she does.
She probably was a mask.
It's really come out and be like,
where's a devil mask and puts a strap on on tennis balls like a racket.
She rackets him in the ass hole maximum in the Asil.
That babies could come out already.
The sizes of the dad was like,
who the fuck is this guy?
Not Know.
Punishing.
Wow.
That's amazing.
I'm shrinking.
You can ask them or just blew out of
Lexis.
A Nice Guy,
but that's just ridiculous.
Good for him for polling.
I'm impressed.
I like it.
That's incredibly not afraid.
Fucking right.
Your dress them up as a beer.
That's incredible.
How did he pull that off to think we had a shot as a smart guy.
Maybe he's just Beta enough to sit back and let her get gorilla fuck by stud
athletes on the sneaker,
right,
sir?
You're talking about the greatest,
but don't you think that she's going to want some like real dick?
No.
Or maybe you might have a real desert Drake before that.
He's not like,
he might have a real dick.
Maybe does.
Oh he might just have the angry red it dick just,
yeah,
and we don't know.
Or girls don't care that much.
How about that?
He pulls it out and smoke comes out of the nose.
Like smell like a hawk.
Oh my God.
I'm not going to have this conversation.
Serina fine.
He just,
he might just be awesome.
Awesome.
My stomach is so full,
so long to buy gold.
Cool.
How about how much you want that tennis tournament at nine,
nine weeks pregnant?
Cause she really,
oh my God,
that's fucking monster.
Let me give you a may me.
She's such a good athlete,
man.
God deck.
I hit the Jackpot having her baby didn't amazing for sure James.
Oh she doesn't need the money.
She's rich as shit.
Yup.
Maybe she just likes nice guys.
He's a really smart dude.
He's white guys.
Yeah.
Interest.
He divided.
She dated to Lavonne Arrington for a little while.
Okay.
How does this fight play out?
There's glow over.
Have anything left.
You know,
Glover knocked out Rashad,
but Glover's got a bum shoulder man and he was having a hard time with his
shoulder and his last fight against Jared cannoneer.
Yeah.
And he had a hard time in training.
If Alex done it.
Gus Finn had his on right.
He's to me,
he's the best light heavyweight in the world.
Really?
Yup.
But DC beat him and Jon Jones,
I think he beat John.
I think he beat DC in that flight.
Well,
he's the best light.
Every weight in the world now that rumbles retired.
You're saying fight.
He got headbutted.
Yeah.
There's a lot of asterisks to me talent wise,
if his,
if his mind's on right,
like remember this fight at one 65 with John,
but it's two heads colliding.
It's not like you're hitting him with a weapon.
I'm say it's a bit of a freak accident.
They fight again.
I bet that fight goes different.
I'm not saying you'd wind machine goes debride,
especially now.
Yeah.
You don't think they have the Johnson that showed up a fight DC would it be,
would be.
I think he was on his way out and that flight.
That's what I'm saying,
that fight,
he just,
it seemed to me like he really just did not want to fight anymore in that.
That's all I'm saying.
Like when he started clinching with DC,
I was like,
what is happening?
Oh,
you can take down.
The Olympiads already had it in his mind.
It was over.
He told everyone weeks before.
That's crazy.
What was camp at?
Family.
I was hearing that he was barely trained for that fight.
That's what I was hearing and I thought it was bullshit.
I was like,
come on,
he's fighting for the title and I was hearing all kinds of shit.
Like he came into training four weeks out,
so I get it.
But if you're one foot in,
one foot out,
you're like,
I might as well get this money.
Just try and wrestle because then you make how much thing you made in that fine
500,000 so I'm Glover is a guy that if he didn't have those six years outside of
the UFC,
I feel like it could've been a champ.
Not with Jon Jones at the helm.
No,
he wouldn't have been a champion.
John John's at the helm.
It would have been before Jon Jones,
who was before John Shogun.
Yeah,
you're right.
It's fair.
He could have probably got a chance.
He had a chance.
He just got right.
Yeah.
It was the visa issue for six fucking years.
When he was in his prime.
He was one guy,
like when he destroyed.
So could you in the WEC back when the WBC was in northern California in the
middle of nowhere.
I remember that.
Yeah.
With Reed was running that read his love for you to just love read.
He's great guy.
He's still with the EOC.
Yes,
I love that guy.
But when Glover back in those days,
Glover was a fucking destroyer,
like a God damn destroyer.
It was like the Brazilian boogey man.
Everyone was like,
dude,
wait until this guy gets to the UFC.
He just,
they're trying to figure out as visa and then chuck Ladell signed off on them
and have them in signed off and then by the time he got there,
you know you had that rampage fight was in grade.
Well,
he fought Kyle Kingsbury and smoked them and then everybody was like Walden.
Nono remaining found him,
but Maldonado clipped him.
Remember that?
Gave him the chicken dance walled analysis.
These,
that secret fricking dad bod box Brazilian boxy clip fade or he beat fade or so
I think he should have been,
I should have beat in Russia.
They're like,
Nah,
you're good.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
Come on,
Bro.
Yeah man.
He tried to,
he tried to protest like you should have protest.
The fact that you got on a plane and went to Russia protested anywhere else.
He won that fight kid.
It's true,
man.
I mean by the new scoring he wanted in a big way.
Easily.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean for Fader,
never really heard him.
Never.
No,
but he heard the shit out of fate or he had a paid or queer straight would have
stopped that fight.
In America.
A lot of times,
especially in New York though fade or took a term where all the men were Marin
dresses,
those queer street.
What do you think happened with fatal or Mitch [inaudible]?
Mitch reone easily could knock 'em out.
Yeah,
early on.
I just think that fate
or is still fade or in bursts,
but I just think if you look at the Maldonado fight,
look,
you're not talking about fate or is private paid.
One is prime kills,
mitre own.
You go back to fade,
orange pride and the pride days,
but mitre on his way,
closer to his prime then fade or is Mitch and Mitch reone has a Chin like a
motherfucker still Roy.
He knocked him out.
Oh boy.
Tki owed him.
He didn't knock him flatland,
flatland,
hit him with a hammer and dropped and dropped and then I'm like,
you know,
Rhonda style or something like that.
I like Mark Kahn was only a couple of punches though.
Yeah,
but I'm just saying he didn't like flat flat line.
Yeah but we,
we both agree he could take it and mitre on is a way better athlete Mitro and is
fastened his feet.
If Mitre on fight smart,
I think he can win that fight.
Just had put that,
that's the key.
There's has to fight smart and people get mad at me for saying that,
but I'm just saying fade or in this day and age,
this fade or the today fade or it's got all those tattoos.
Chest.
A lot of people would a lot of fade or fanboys.
Oh dammit.
It's 2017 you fucks.
It's just hard when I get mad cause he said wonder they had fucking surgery on
his face.
It's life shit happen.
I would like to see fade or take the veto route and get over to rising and let's
get this party started.
You know,
just stay in Belgium and just keep it in Russia.
Cabinet isn't trained in Sweden or does he have a camp and that all these glass
bottles,
listen,
these books,
these glass bottles or victory solid name.
Let's bring it back to that.
The golden years t we're going to get you on the TRT bunch of gets done.
Then I get on that a Hugh Jackman sauce and I draw a 50 and a trial cannot the
shit that makes you grow.
Eyebrow hair.
If your forehead starts getting hairy and and shorter.
Right here you got somebody,
uh,
what,
where does he train Gustafson in Sweden or does he have his camp somewhere else?
Um,
that's a good question.
And he doesn't use,
do a lot of alliance in San Diego,
but I don't know.
This camp in Sweden did.
Yeah,
the whole camp we'll manimal was with them.
I know Manoa did some training with them and other tramps,
tattoos,
the tattoos.
And he's got a native American,
he's got a wolf and he's got the,
is that the club?
I could jack of spades.
Yeah.
And he's got all those little lines,
or like when he fights,
every time he fights he gets a new one.
And the ones that he wins are dark and the ones that he loses or white,
and then the ones that he'd get,
I guess I draw.
I was like a,
how do I,
that might be my tattoo.
It's a touch of white lines.
Gustafson is the top two daddies.
He's also a dude.
Yeah,
Gloria's has been around those six years.
Cost him hard,
man.
Fuck that.
There'd been this goddamn prime.
Right?
Have you spent a lot of time,
like the nicest guy ever?
Clovers,
the best savage behind the eyes and you think you hate you,
but really he's cool.
He's a sweetheart.
He's a really,
really good guy.
Brazilian with a Russian mentality.
Oh,
he's a killer.
And you know,
I mean,
it didn't help that he was fucking left out for six years.
Well look,
he put Rashad away last year,
but then Glover,
I mean a rampage,
excuse me,
a rumble,
put them away with one punch bump with knocked
his teeth out.
He knocked his fucking sold out.
His soul had to come back down.
Gravity had to put his soul back down.
And you see how far that tooth went crazy.
Especially in slow.
She was,
I thought that was CGI.
Is it definitely a tooth?
It flew out of his mouth.
I think it was spit.
I think a Gustafson.
If he shows up,
shouldn't merch blow?
Right?
Hate to tell you.
I think it works.
I mean interest.
I think you beat them up.
Interesting.
And then Glover be ranking way behind my boy who just won tonight.
I'm really interested to see that mature on fade or fight.
I'm going to buy that.
I'll buy that on paper view.
I'm also really interested in to see Lorens Larkin Lorez mark and versus Douglas
Lema.
Which one?
Diego Lima's.
The UFC guy was fighting in the UFC.
The Douglas Lema.
Yeah.
Douglas Lema.
The bell torture.
Yeah.
Correct.
He's a fucking duties.
Chandler too.
I love watching that card is fucking posey.
Rory motherfucking macdonald looked as good as any welterweight on the planet.
He is.
He might be champ,
you know,
beat the champion,
be Damien by and lost the wonder Wonderboy.
But still,
he's the one who bought it,
but his nose was jacked.
Her fight.
How good did he look?
Phenomenal.
And then he said it and they go,
do you have a message for,
uh,
Lima or,
a month or a fucking like Larkin?
He goes,
ah,
I'm going to take your belt on the take your health.
Yeah,
I'm out.
I'm going to take your belt and dead.
Serious.
Dead serious.
He's dead Sara.
Well,
he,
he told me that he spent a lot of time working on improving his game while he
was taking the time off to heal his nose.
He's like,
he's just sparked too much as no,
just kept opening up and it was a real problem.
His nose got smashed in.
The Robbie Lawler fight.
He never,
never gave a chance to see.
He said when he got hit,
it all went white in the blood,
like rushed into the,
his face.
He said everything was white.
He just couldn't see him.
He was like,
fuck.
Because who knows Roy?
He knows he's a monster warrior.
Like they're happy.
Some batch it again to stop.
I Glover's taller than I thought.
I mean it's a big dude.
I don't know if the angle of the camera cameras the angle Guston's fucking six
six.
He's Tustin's huge.
Yeah.
Um,
Glover has a fucked up right shoulder from the John Jones fight.
Jon Jones Glover had an under hook on John Jones.
John Jones wrap the arm and yanked his shoulder.
It was [inaudible].
I get so nervous for a guy who was fighting in his home town.
How good is John?
John Dismantle Clever.
I was like,
Oh you,
oh,
you're good.
Check this up.
Yeah.
If I see one more advertisement for fucking Logan,
I'm about to bust bust.
They are really coming hard with that.
Logan had God get it out of my face in alcoholic and it forgot aggressive.
I like the way this guy,
I liked the way customers is moving guys.
Sad side to it right now it goes through in wrestling too is very underrated.
But clover can grapple the best of black belt.
Ahboo dobby competition.
He's a monster who could kick more knocked out.
Power Clover Club is great boxer man.
Nice uppercut.
Oh boy.
Be careful.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright,
let's calm down.
Calm down.
Glover also underwriting wrestling.
Ah,
that's right.
On the city is grappling is really,
really good.
Good Little San Francisco guests and loses again as hometown.
It's a little nervous sometimes.
He's a little nervous.
Remember we got lost a fucking Johnson and his home town was mia for a fucking
year.
It's tough when you're the hometown hero man.
Well it's also,
you trained so hard for this one big moment and then you lose and you got to
like reassess.
Like where am I?
He was on billboards and shit.
He still only 30 that's another thing to think about with Alexander.
He's 30 years old.
He's in his athletic prime.
It's just a little nervous right now.
I feel like you dare you.
How dare he?
Little hesitant.
I dare you judge this man.
I'm nervous.
I'm going to have him tweet about your writing.
Don't you fucking dare to,
how funny would that trolling me about my fucking writing?
Oh,
oh there you got to write here.
Oh Nice.
Wow.
Yeah,
he's twice.
He was hesitant.
He just loosen up.
John Gustafson cause of that rumble,
that jab son told him to come forward.
Need Up.
What keeps you?
I don't like get away from that right hand,
man,
man.
Cause this is good though.
Oh,
it's called little checkup there.
I used to wake him up called call.
Wake me up.
All right.
She was just avoiding it.
That's smart man.
Good movement.
That's the Overeem tactic there.
We ran away.
Deal for him.
Remember when you started doing that and it worked?
Long legs.
Look at this shit.
Look at this long arms fuck.
Who was the one dude that Nate quarry Fox.
There was literally running away from him.
Caleb stone.
Caleb Lipstein.
That's right.
And Nate Quarry was,
was Cohen after him like this.
But I think he goes,
no,
he covered his eyes.
Yeah,
but it wasn't hurting that fight.
He wasn't hurt his foot.
He fucked his foot up running.
That was a terrible fight.
Wasn't good.
It ruined Caleb's career.
Yeah.
People were so
shocked him.
He poked him.
Jesus Christ.
Well,
I guess if he put his hand down down first and he hit him with the upper cut,
goddammit.
He poked him first and then we'll see in the replay.
What happened.
Shit,
if this is in New York,
Oh,
Glover wins the fight.
No,
no contest.
Fuck.
This is the worst part of fighting as he's got damn iPad.
Glover's finds some.
All right.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
he's lucky that I missed.
I missed.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let's see if they can get a bit.
Oh Man,
look at that right in there.
That's the worst.
But that's the other eye.
Is He?
Oh,
his right eye or hours left.
Both eyes.
Do you get poked him both times?
He that a bitch.
Well,
maybe he's like squinting with his left leg was saying,
I'm going to fight.
Get out of the way.
That's what you want.
Some of those young guys be like,
I don't know.
It's tough globally to get the fuck out of my way.
The old eye gouge for a street fighting.
Most Kung Fu guys are onto something.
Oh,
they were on something.
Eagle Claw,
tiger,
Paul,
Tiger and Eagle.
I use both.
Brians did you see that video where that Tai-chi guy fights the MMA guy?
I did not.
It's uh,
it lasted like a few sac.
Did you send me that Joe?
Yeah.
Like yeah,
tell him I may got crushed with them and then the MMA guy I had to go into
hiding because apparently people in China want to kill him because it's like a
disgrace to the Chinese martial arts.
So it's not a march.
It's not part of that right hand be it's their fault.
Oh,
that's a beautiful upper cut.
So long you get out too.
It's a nice open man.
Yeah.
Gustafson looking slick dude.
I'm really champ.
Him and John,
man,
that's the fucking fight.
It might be
Muy Bien.
Well now that rumbles out of the picture,
I mean Gustafson,
you got to remember,
did rock out Jimmy marijuana as a right hand over the top.
I wonder how they handle that now.
They've been training together.
You know Gus Gus January beat Manoa.
Yeah,
he knocked him out.
But I wonder how they handled that because if man was still in the mix,
if they do eventually have to cross paths again,
I'm not trying to see that again.
Well,
it's so thin and they have to,
they have to fight again.
It's almost like flyweight like who the fuck is there?
No,
you,
you look at this running away the stone and then stop.
Oh,
he clipped him with that opera cut again again with the upper cut,
left hook.
Get out of there and then he'd go,
I'm not mad at this tactic.
Clover swinging for the fences to backache.
We've got five rounds of this boys.
I love this fight,
man.
Dustbin John Too.
Are you kidding me?
I'd love to see Gus and John Too.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Dumb shit that everybody listen again.
Cost of sin.
30 years old.
He's still young man.
A lot of fight left Joe.
You know he's had a lot of fights too though.
Yeah,
he has had some wars too.
Yeah.
John is fight.
DC was award.
John was a fucking war.
And you've got a beating from rumble.
Yeah.
Other than that,
it's kind of Ooh,
fakes the take down.
This is an interesting fight.
The way it's playing out.
Glover's chasing them down,
man.
I hope he can get them pinned.
It's got to get inside of that reading comprehension.
Not Wonder if blowers going to time that with an overhand right.
He's got to try,
but you got to remember his right hands.
The one that's fucked up,
his shoulder and his right.
It's a fucked up kid up.
I get a [inaudible].
I love this scope.
Scope.
Best you want me to help you out?
I out of your giant.
Should I secure?
How about this fucking Golden State?
Cavs
basketball aren't.
Yeah,
I'll throw up.
Throw up on this table.
I will watch that basketball.
Fuck you guys.
It goes in the net and I get so excited and haven't got pissed buddy.
It's crazy when the ball goes in and that I've never seen like it.
Jamie gets mad.
Well,
it's not what it's about.
It's part of the things but more important things.
Both athletics.
It's both the best of the best players in the world.
Coach,
you know which one it for coaching.
It is a great sport,
but you know,
you know which they're making
Jamie oppression.
I make fun of a Jamie's a sneakers and he makes fun of underarmour suite.
You weren't under Armour like so what's wrong with under Armour?
Like in the world of like sneaker sneaker dorks is under Armour like shots got
200 pairs of sneakers and clothes.
Yeah.
What's it like?
That's like number four or five in the list of hierarchy.
Same Dog trainer Ryan.
Yeah.
We'll talk.
Yup.
Here we go.
Round dose to two two,
two was that Double Jab at Gustafson.
Very interesting fight.
Oh,
how's your dog?
Great.
What?
You got a German shepherd?
I had a German shepherd girl or boy Carl.
Is she cool with your kids the best?
I'll never have another dog besides the German shepherd.
Yup.
My working line chapter,
there's nothing.
I've had dogs my whole life.
I,
they're just different animals.
They're so keyed in to you.
They listen to you and they're wary of strangers.
Man.
They don't fuck around.
Amazing washe talks,
but they can dissent.
They can not dog aggressive.
Uh,
they stay with you.
That the best.
I love him.
Mr Shop's going to get one.
I love German shepherds to what I don't like is ones that don't get trained well
and they bite.
Kids know that you don't,
that's that's why you get a job with [inaudible] talking about dogs.
Malibu Malinois Malinois Belgian malinois today.
Today,
train today.
Whenever I'll let you know.
A lot of people don't like Belgium Mel walls cause they're,
they're almost a little too gay are,
but he's got a,
he's got a special one.
This one I saw the picture he sent me.
He saw that picture.
Just things going to this thing.
We'll inhale and intruder.
Yeah.
Those mother fuckers don't play.
They cut again.
Pop.
What caught his eye?
What happened?
Headbutting.
I don't know.
Yeah,
but guts since plan.
Now look at us.
Look at us.
Brian was talking about working dogs.
I'm obsessed with uh,
to give him that he does.
He'll too.
And Dogs B C here in the dog and the guns you into fighting.
I ain't talk about cars and turn up.
What's up.
I only have so much in my brain,
brothers.
You know what it is,
man.
You've never driven one probably.
Yeah.
That's all I need though,
right?
Oh,
careful with that.
Runaway clothes.
I'd rather him time up and fucking gloves and get punched in the face.
He's bleeding bad out of that and there was getting picked apart in the middle
of the octagon.
Yeah,
it's fucking,
oh,
Gotcha,
Gotcha.
Oh,
glow was in trouble.
Big trouble.
When's the last time I saw that?
My Cart Tyrone Woodley.
Stop Horse.
Oh boy.
Wow.
What a combination.
Spinning elbow kid.
I seen that on dummies.
Gustafson coming alive.
Gfsi centers tell any man that real fuss like the hill.
Chava sang it a long time ago.
She gets back.
I'll give him that.
The one thing he's right about with fighting was Gus,
look at his face.
Clovers faces a mask.
It's a mess right now,
but again,
close that guy.
He has so much knock out power.
It's like one shot.
Oh,
great body shot.
Yeah.
Very good.
Causes us to be an issue for him.
Maybe I remember the book.
He knows you trained with gfes and you spar with both these guys.
Yeah,
I remember you saying that way before you like he's the real deal.
Uh,
best I've ever trained with hands down.
Gustafson's yes.
By far.
Biggest freak I've ever seen.
I can't believe it,
man.
He,
he was so good at everything,
you know,
outside of new,
he was really good.
Uh,
his size.
I watched him spar with a,
you know,
a world champion boxer.
It literally eight rounds and just do work on the dude,
straight up boxing world champion who was the world champion.
Forget the guy's name.
You know how many belts are if some guy,
you know,
but he,
he,
he literally went in there,
did work,
gets him that,
jumped out,
went three rounds with me.
It was,
I was,
I mean,
wow.
So sparring with them,
just botched it up box.
Oh Shit.
And fucking I'm up.
Got when you were to share is still in this fight guys.
He was straight up box in the streams going,
don't knock them out,
Alexander.
Do not knock them out.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
I wonder if Alexander ever thought about actually just boxing.
I don't know.
Nice front kick to the side of that.
Oh Jesus.
But the left over is doing work,
but you look at his fight with Jon Jones fight.
To me,
that's the greatest light heavyweight fight of all time.
I was fucking so thrilled with that fight,
man.
Amazing.
Because there's finally John John's kind of met his match.
Granted John Probably had two hours of sleep and do a bunch of lines of coke,
so who knows now,
but still at the time it was great.
I don't like this funding away because clover's going to time this shit man.
You think?
I think so and worries me all your years of fighting.
Have you ever seen that happen?
Yes.
I'm Mr. O'Brien
when Mr over and
I don't teach my,
I don't teach my students to do all the time.
So let me ask you guys this while we're watching the fight,
what's the best set up to do a fight companion?
Because I'm building a fight companions studio in the next place.
I feel like chef punching bags that we can hit out of frustration or anxiety.
Well,
what I'm thinking is the way we're sitting here across from each other and
watching the fights is not totally ideal.
I'm thinking round table.
More like a semi circle.
Like a half moon.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Almost like an analyst desk.
And then the t v there.
But this way we're all be like,
oh,
that's cool.
That's what I've been thinking.
A great idea.
But we should have a desk,
right?
It's good to have a desk and drink some shirts and stuff.
So I'm going to set up a second thing just in front of a big ass TV and I'm
thinking of putting a big ass TV like even
bigger than this month.
I can protect that idea.
No,
no,
no.
Like 110 inch LCD.
Bam.
Look at this Combo.
Beautiful.
It could also be,
we can ask a big couch.
I want him.
Would that make us too tired?
That's what I think.
These chairs are the shit,
these chairs,
these,
uh,
these are people keep asking.
I'll tell there's not a sponsor.
Ergo depot sent me these.
They're from there.
They're called capisce goes in.
There are Ergonomic Tommy buttons.
It has these now Thompson or has these in his podcasts.
Ergo what?
Depo chairs at our second,
e r g o t depot.com.
And these fucking chairs are excellent because they're comfortable,
but they're also ergonomics.
So like you sit up straight because you sit up straight after the end of the
show.
Your back doesn't fucking matter at all because you don't do a couch for the no,
no couches.
I think where these chairs are it for podcasts.
I think I found the holy grail of podcast chairs.
Great.
They're amazing.
The question.
So the question was what kind of set up she would have like side tables and I
think,
no,
I think,
I think a table in front of us is the way I sent,
because Brian's always bringing wine and cheese and shit.
Yup.
Yeah.
We're always going to want to slide things down to each other and this stuff.
Then you should have like give just a area.
It looks like a,
uh,
like an old school telephone booth.
It's called conspiracy theories.
And then fucking Eddie goes in there.
Now what I'm going to have is a second thing with experts on Skype on standby
waiting.
Every time Eddie says something crazy,
I'm going to press a button and boom,
Neil degrasse Tyson,
you're on the line.
Do you know what I think we should have?
Should have a grill and somebody should be cooking.
Oh,
oh.
Oh my God.
Marius.
Trouble.
Serious trouble letting my brain no,
no,
no.
But is in some serious trouble here man.
If you have to cover,
but she might or might get grounded out.
Well,
you got to posture up and he's clip.
Oh my God.
I have a Bosch Yoder 1500,
which is a huge commercial smoker for the studio.
You should have asked.
It should be a cooking show.
We should have somebody shoot.
I'm way ahead of you.
You've been listening to my podcast or something?
No,
I'm doing cooking shows.
Thank you.
I'm going to do cook.
Oh,
the last one I did with Tom Papa.
We talked about it.
We're going to sit down and eat dinner.
I'm going to cook it on the show,
right?
We're going to sit down and eat dinner on the podcasts and you're gonna hear a
lot of that drives house is going for the arm bar.
It will drive you nuts,
but you will know that it's going to be happening.
So hopefully it won't drive you.
It will be,
it'll be a fight companion.
So we'll be eating game.
We'll be eating man.
Meet shrinking.
Amazing.
Why don't be a party pooper,
Brendan?
Well,
what I'm thinking is we're not going to do that during fight companion then
there's too much going on.
So no,
it's going to be like a show.
We sit down and have a meal.
You know,
you watch those Anthony Bourdain shows,
he's talking to some fucking lady in Sardinia.
You don't even know what the hell she's saying.
And it's interesting,
right?
You're like,
I love a good meal,
having a good meal,
and I'm going to bring guys like Hank Shaw have them cooked for us.
Oh,
nice trip.
I love Hank Shaw,
who's a world class game chef.
Ooh.
And a hunter.
Really?
Yeah.
If you get like some hooter girls to like refill our con stuff,
sir.
Sorry.
Oh,
I'm all,
oh,
you're back.
Well,
Brian's doing all the meat and cooking.
You're all about that and I want to get a couple of smoke shows to fill up our
coffees and all of a sudden I'm fucking solves it here.
They get good lane,
bro.
They're paid to be class time.
Ian brought his girlfriend over by paid to shut the fuck out.
They don't get paid enough.
That's not even possible.
Feminist.
I'm offended.
You see wonder woman?
Oh,
when only seen it.
Women only get to see went to the,
I went to the screenings with just women.
I liked it.
I liked that.
I wanted to come here anyways,
let's get back these hooter bitches that refill on coffee.
You guys hit or not,
man,
I want something to do with this.
Stay.
He chipped.
Peer pressure.
I guess I am now.
They just feed us like beef jerky.
Beef jerky feed it to you.
That's weird.
Something wrong with your hands,
but I'm definitely had to bring in some chefs and have some food cook.
Dude,
that's a great idea.
Jamie.
Pull up the Yoder 1500 and you show these motherfuckers off to his landing all
day long and it costs for behind the jab so he's like blinded by the jazz.
So long you can get away with it.
Yup.
Line blind them and bring them up.
Gustafson looks fantastic.
He beats everybody.
Do you think he beat John Jones?
I do.
Really?
If Jon Jones fought him with this long of a layoff,
like let's say they were going to fight and I don't know when you've taught Osp.
Yes,
he gets fucked up.
Oh look at this.
Look at this creative.
It really thinks so.
That's interesting.
Oh Shit.
It's all you buddy.
He looks outstanding here tonight.
Oh God.
With the lover is still in this fight in every way.
Clover is a fucking animal.
He's fighting for his life,
man.
He's fighting for his cribs.
What he's doing,
I mean he's 37 years old.
He doesn't have much time left and these are,
these opportunities are few and far between.
Headlining a major card like,
oh,
you can take a shot.
And he's go over saying,
come on,
come on.
They're both fighting for calling him,
man.
You lose this one.
Come on to clover.
So aggressive.
It's crazy.
Even getting tagged like he's getting,
he's still in this.
See that baby right there.
Damn.
See that's a sick,
that's a sick grilled machines.
Of course.
Rogan,
ESCO,
extreme with the grill.
That's a smoker.
It's like,
well it grows.
It smokes.
You could do everything on not just spit ball ideas.
Let's toss a fucking zebra in the,
I need a zero.
What are you eating now?
What?
What do you,
what do you have in your freezer?
Mostly elk.
Gosh,
I feel about 400 pounds.
What about some ribs?
Ribs that,
see that's what I'm talking about.
I shot a pig last money and still have some thighs.
We eat.
The ribs are ready,
but I uh,
I have some.
Yeah,
I did.
I not eat.
I didn't need all the ribs.
Are you at a barbecue guy?
Do you have a,
you're
looking at that.
Oh man,
we should have a grill off cause I can grill my gas on going to have to have a
real life.
How do you grill?
What do you do?
Do you a charcoal guy?
Nah,
gas.
Gas,
That's not even a nice filets ribs.
Fish,
salmon.
Especially that's a queer oven.
Nah Son.
Some weird of,
it's the Tesla of grills.
Justin Timberlake and Chris.
Funny to hear this.
Selling nothing.
No,
they both own.
A Timberlake owns a part of this company.
What does that make sense?
Antioxidant infusion.
Not just drink actual juice.
You fucks which you juice.
You don't.
God Damn Barry's.
Watch this.
Look at this combination.
Yep.
Boom.
He's Matrix.
Shitty falling down there and land back in the Matrix.
Shit by Gustafson.
Look at this.
Bing,
bing,
bing.
Look,
get him.
Come on,
bring it.
Come on.
He said,
God damn.
Glover's tough.
So can be sharp as a knife.
10 years from now,
TRT,
get them onto Yardi.
Everybody,
the whole buddy,
the whole crew,
everybody including the garage.
We got a problem with Cyborg.
Everybody catch up.
Here we go.
Okay.
I love sidebar graph to that podcast you did with her Brennan.
Thanks man.
You didn't love her before.
I love her anyway,
but I didn't know her,
but she's a beast.
She's awesome as a fighter.
She's a fucking beast,
man.
There's no question about that.
It seems like a good person too though.
That's what I like about her.
He would go,
that up.
Cut is coming in from fucking stock.
Stockholm.
Oh,
it goes to the body with a whip.
Oops.
They didn't want that brought worst.
Right,
so fucking
come on.
Come on.
It's crazy to me.
Like globe or is just still fucking pumping away.
He looks like he's still a profit around looking to knock them out and yeah,
we're in round four clover looks how you would make a fighter in a video of
Jesus.
Just faking that.
Oh God.
That left overcome with the right hand over the top.
How global.
It doesn't train with like any super camps or nothing really?
No,
not even straight out of like a garage in Connecticut hand.
Yeah,
that's what he does now,
right?
Yeah.
He has a school in Connecticut.
Didn't he go to att for a while?
Yeah,
he did,
but he lives in Connecticut.
Inspiring place to live at all the places to go.
You're from Brazil and he moved to Connecticut and wonder why maybe drives
what?
Yeah.
You learn to parents had a house in Connecticut for 10 years.
One of the few places I never perform again.
Bucket.
Yup.
How can inside joke people getting mad?
People from Connecticut and sending me messages.
Come on Bro too.
They have a big a city though.
Yeah.
Hartford.
Hartford though.
It's not a big city,
but it's definitely a city for ESPN,
for Bristol.
I feel like that's all there is.
And could that be,
why the fuck you lay there?
Dig Taxes.
Oh,
other there.
Because it's right next to New York City and you can get a nice large,
large plot of land and make sense.
Big Rich investment bankers living grant makes sense.
Yeah.
That's where a David Letterman lives.
David let them live there.
Got himself off a state.
I'd be the motherfucker,
a huge estate Nolan.
He balled.
They've got an estate.
Fuck.
I don't think he does anything anymore though.
Dude.
Dave is a,
I think he's just kind of like chill him.
No,
he counts as money I think.
Yeah.
Just where these crib in Atlanta is a fucking castle.
I'm sure he's got some Chitta Golf.
Jeff Foot.
The redneck toward
yeah,
him and uh,
Ron White.
I love that podcast you did with him.
That's great.
Okay.
Dave.
That's Dave Letterman.
Holy Shit.
That's what global scale like in 30 years.
Oh my.
He looks like glow or show like,
well,
didn't know Dave have heart surgery.
I feel like he had a holy fuck.
Yeah.
I feel like he had heart surgery.
Oh my God.
He looks horrible.
All right.
It just looks like,
remember when Tim Allen became Santa Claus?
Yeah.
I love each gets to us all.
I looked at a picture of me with 10 years ago when I was 40 you'll always
handsome.
You look exactly the same about that.
You're so delicious.
Really good.
David.
Thank you.
Books.
That's,
that's what I've been looking for on a Sunday.
It was,
shit,
I'm Brian Day and now it's turned into.
Now it's get,
at what point in life do you just say we have fuck you money.
You say fuck you life where you just let your body go into seat,
whatever.
Cause I'm sure a lot of people are doing things,
but when you were in the public eye like,
oh,
he clipped him with a right hand over the top.
When you're in the public eye,
like a David Letterman,
like most of your life,
and then you decided you decided to not do that anymore,
then it becomes kind of interesting.
You can relax.
You have to be disappointed by your look and make them look.
It's that 10 years ago.
Look at that Cutie Pie or similar,
I assume not.
I was so much.
They look exactly the same on dude.
I appreciate it.
The drawback is 30 to 40 that's where you're really dropped off,
but 40 to 50 if you're maintaining,
maintaining my,
seems like you work out more now.
I do work out every day and it doesn't do much.
Here's someone's alarm going on like,
God,
yeah,
I do.
Good ears.
I think I have bad ears by the way.
You probably do with age,
son.
Get them dig.
I'm always asking my wife to turn the cell.
The boxing.
You do?
Yeah.
We'll do it.
Years of getting boxed in my ears.
He getting boxed up.
Borough clover's fucking just go away.
Game.
He didn't get the menu.
The fucking memo.
Good kick to the body there.
We're good.
Lower still looking for that knockout punch,
man.
That's a fast,
always there.
The scary thing is if,
oh shit,
if Alexander slows down a little bit,
it gets the club was for me.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That Combo Stud.
He needs to stay in the middle of the AUC gun.
Got Some certain yes.
Looks as good as he's ever looked in this fight.
Yeah.
It really does like being them at light.
Heavyweight is so fluid and this movement is excellent.
It's a big fight for him,
man.
Oh boy.
For both of them,
it's kind of career defining to be honest.
I hate to be good.
How many can you take of these?
Strange,
what's going on here?
Beautiful.
It's artistic performance,
man.
It really is the way he's been hiding that opera cut is my favorite top in that
jab.
Is He your favorite for you?
Have a unique insight.
Knowing exactly how good he is.
Having trained with them.
You know,
I trained with both of them with clover.
I just,
you know,
I understand what he's doing in his pacing and he's like the terminator.
He's very similar to it.
That's why I'd love to see him in DC fight cause I've trained with and they have
very similar styles,
which just this relentless,
relentless forward pressure and you're like God damn relax.
Slow down.
Speaking on a relentless to,
you're running like eight miles.
I've seen you run in like some long distances.
Where are you running a outside my crib.
He just run the beach or something like that on concrete or concrete in those
campaigns.
Shoes.
But my knees fucked up so I'm suing Kim.
Why are you,
why are you running on concrete when the sand is right there?
Uh,
I dunno cause I like to run,
but this is like sand better for you because the,
I run the San Marcus so I do is I run one Santa Monica stairs and I run a mile
to Samak stairs.
Run a mile,
three sentences,
run a mile.
That's what I'm doing.
Oh,
interesting.
So the stairs are like to sprint and then the mile was,
but my new yesterday was like,
Nah,
let's take a break bro.
I'm way too big.
If you're a heavy guy,
what do you weigh?
Like two 42 40 a to 38 yeah,
that's a lot of weight to put on the knees.
I know,
man.
I got to figure it out.
I got to do something.
If you guys know what to do,
it's the inside of my knee,
but okay,
let me ask you this.
What do you think about this UFC training facility?
Like who's going to go there?
I was so,
and they're going to pump Bain like products into his body.
Fucking in between Brown division in between rounds.
He steps in a Cryo Chamber,
by the way,
I'm sorry,
but look at Glover and round four.
After all that punishment keeping his head,
he looks very fresh that one of the problems with glow is he's so boxing
oriented in his attack and with a guy like Gustafson,
he has such a large reach disadvantage.
So he's constantly moving forward,
but he doesn't throw kicks.
Oh.
Or a gusts when stop kick in because he got taken down early on.
But his kid,
his kicks too.
I don't just abandoned it.
Keeping Away with us for Glover.
Glover has always got to move into boxing changed.
Boy.
Oh my God.
God.
What a fucking
shit.
Gustafson clover.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I don't like seeing that at all.
I don't like seeing that at all
is a fucking beast.
That was brilliant.
God Damn,
that was brilliant.
That was brilliant,
man.
Holy Shit.
This is in Sweden.
Stockholm,
Stockholm.
Come around it down in Stockholm.
It's a fucking hero.
He's a hero.
He's a ledge.
And the,
the heartbreak you went through when he wants to fucking Johnson there.
Man,
I was there,
man.
I feel like crying,
crying that they were walking out of the arena with her head low was,
it was rough and it was a bad beating too.
You know,
fucking redemption.
What a viking.
What a fight.
Here's redemption.
Redemption is John Jones Beats DC and airline.
They didn't do karate.
Jones Alexander cuffs in Stockholm.
Title.
Good.
You're not going to do it in Stockholm.
They do it in Vegas.
The real money's at Vegas,
unfortunately.
That's bull shit.
That's just how it goes.
But that's the reason why we haven't been a doubling yet for Conor McGregor
fight being what we could do.
A soccer fucking stadium.
Oh,
Jannie keeps doing the same combo and the right hand.
How much was that right away,
right?
Stupid fast.
A dude.
And he's like,
not enough.
Huh?
Go.
Oh,
beautiful timing to the way he swung that right hand into,
look how he swings and right hand and over the left guard.
Look at this.
Watch this.
See look.
There's swings that right hand over the top corners like,
do,
do you think you want to kind of avoid the upper cut?
He's like,
Nah,
we'll keep doing this.
There's nothing we can do.
We just gets hit and hit buys.
What are you going to do?
God,
that was brilliant man.
Brilliant performance.
When you were saying how glow or just missed the it,
the it a little bit like that Boston with his wrestling style via brand page.
He had been champ him first rampage in the prime.
That's a motherfucking fight.
Yeah,
he could've won.
He could have won.
But you know what's interesting is that he just,
because he doesn't throw very many kicks,
I mean he might throw in 10 kicks,
that whole fight.
He's always moving into boxing ranks.
She's getting chewed up on the way in and it's tough as he is.
He's still getting tagged over and over and over.
2017 if you're just boxing,
you're screwed man named guy who's just boxing too alone.
The UFC.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
You really have to do whatever the highest level.
You just can't do it anymore.
Like guys figure it out.
Yeah,
you really have to be able to do everything.
So this UFC training facility,
like how much did that fucking thing cost?
I was looking at that when they were showing the athletes retreat crazier.
I was like how much do you think that costs?
12 million performances to always sang at $12 million performances too.
That's a bargain.
I've seen some types of good deal.
She said but that's in his paper in Vegas.
That's like the size of fucking Lambeau field.
Like that's huge.
It's still though.
And what's it made for?
It's made for people when they're in town.
Yeah,
everything is there.
They have bags,
doctors and doctors and they have a those aquatic,
that's what I was going to bring up.
They have those underwater treadmills and I fell down the Mbas as I have not
done that.
That is what you should do like for your big ass bro.
I'm trying to run outside man.
Let's try and run under water like a why fucking why project?
I shot it right outside.
You don't want to be loving side man rocky for,
I'm not doing it because I'm trying to fucking scientific experiments under
Gusteson.
Do you see they're making a to 25 division?
They are.
Yeah.
That's a good idea.
They're also going to do a 10 pound up.
They're going to do do like 55 65 75 wish they had that when I was around.
Wow.
That's a really good idea.
We thinking about coming back.
No.
What?
What is a soul that was shown on the strip?
You get punched in the face anymore.
Just check till you take towards your breakdown.
Way Better Fun.
That's my life.
You weren't,
you're hitting Mitts in your trainer was like,
Hey,
keep your hand on your hair.
I don't give a shit.
I don't even see Jack Craig.
What are you doing?
I'm just doing this to have a summer body NAV or correct.
My Technique Avenue I got for 10 years.
Look at that body summer body coming up son.
You're very excited about that.
I loved this incline bench to get that shelf going.
I'm kind of not talking about,
you were talking about the honor Quito.
The on it.
Yeah.
The kido shake.
What's in your Kido shake?
There was something on the honor,
the liver and Ron.
No,
God Dang.
Oh Dang.
It's like his waiting for you man.
Super Bad for you fucking stop cheese.
It's just crazy.
I already shipping Stockholm right hand.
He,
yeah.
This is crazy how he kept hitting him with the scene.
Combination Jab,
Uppercut,
Jab,
uppercut,
Bang.
It's fun to watch but it feel sorry for Glover.
Yeah,
but I feel happy for Alexandra to man,
that's the life.
Great Guy.
Are you,
you're still on the Kido kick?
Yeah,
pretty much.
I cheat though.
Yeah,
me too.
I'll cheat a couple of days a week at pf Chang's last night.
Fat Shit too.
Like I went nuts.
I had ramen noodles this morning with eggs to drama.
It was so unhealthy so you don't realize it.
It's so bad for you see it all the time as a kid.
Hey Dad,
pay 10 Jamie,
one of the worst things you can eat.
I have like six a day and I would take the two seasons.
His fucking girlfriend put two seasonings in one,
so it was extra flavorful.
Oh yeah.
I like that.
Yeah.
Not to only you can answer it.
Ameriflux a beef for shrimp.
What's going on here?
Is he asking her to marry him?
Don't do it.
Every point.
They're going to happen.
Nice kid on them though.
They aren't good at that.
Kid's going to be out kicking.
Why do I feel like they already have a kid?
Hopefully they do and she had a powerful Rolex on.
I feel like they already have a kid and he's just like making it a fish.
You know what that ring,
if you're gonna do on TV,
a better be a heater.
I like it.
I was doing it with the fucking gloves on.
He should just lift up her skirt and bang around.
Hey,
this is a sacred moments.
Got Those Viking.
Imagine if he did that.
Just animal,
so that's awesome.
Look at those two vikings.
They're going to have some fucking,
maybe she knows.
She knows how he is.
She just picks up her fucking skirt or saw she does it.
She doesn't see that a six foot two.
Hey,
why are they the same size?
What the fuck is going on?
She's got high heels on,
but she's every bit naturally six feet.
She's a six foot or easy.
It's a big old healthy woman and she's a little,
he'll sheets gonna go rack of ribs.
I like broad shoulders.
She's a biking.
Yeah,
I do not.
I do not hate at all.
A girl who's healthy like that.
Who eats good?
No,
it looks great that day that a baby have a baby together doing a beat shop style
of the kid and then you do that.
You tune it out.
Right.
That's awesome.
Kid is going to be good for him.
Yeah.
Mm.
He put on a fucking performance of his career tonight.
Well,
he's got to move mason to jump up to,
yeah.
No,
he's not.
He's number one.
He's number one for sure,
but that's just because John Jones is on the banned list.
My boy Vulcan's like to say what happened number one.
Hey,
I'm number one.
Alexander asked Amir.
Yeah.
Going to move up to probably four now.
I was in mirror with one punch,
four clovers giving.
Go ahead and jump back in line behind this UFC training institute.
That's what I'm so confused like what is ending?
No one's going to do their camp there.
How could you,
how?
How fair would that be if you fight it out?
Let's say Michael Bisbing doing his camp there and you El Students Camp in
Florida and you,
I was like,
wait,
I want to do my camp that he's
gay.
Jay's arts.
Don't fuck it.
She Thought,
oh,
forget it.
Jesus.
God,
they fucked up till that.
Don't forget Jesus and baby Jesus.
It's open to anybody.
You can start or end your camp here.
We have the best training facility.
It makes no sense.
I'm just confused as to what they're trying to do with it.
I just know when I'm in Vegas you fucks.
You're going to train there.
Fuck yeah.
I bet you're not.
You don't get it,
but they won't let you have time.
I will.
I was going to make
you a celebrity.
Not really them.
If I tell him I called the UFC instead,
I'd like to get tickets.
They'd hook it up.
I explain to them where are they now.
That's that phase can be tough.
My feelings are already tight ship.
Depends on how this,
this thing,
this pilot,
the Goldbergs girls that didn't go.
You didn't find out?
No,
you didn't tell me this kind of awkward but the governor's got picked up for two
more years.
Either way.
My Heart's still.
Yeah.
How often do you want it?
Like always be almost famous.
I've realized my partner sells how fucking theaters and now Australia,
you know,
isn't that better though?
Like it keeps you humble I guess.
I suppose to a guy like shop was just rocketing up the charts.
He's eventually going to get a big head tilt.
I mean,
and it's also like you,
you'll have the fuel of being bitter because you are more famous when you guys
started and then he surpasses,
that's been the case.
That's been the case in my career.
That's where my career,
but everybody does that to me.
Get the fuck out.
It'd be awesome.
I'm a failure.
What do you,
well,
you're not a failure.
You're a very successful God.
I'm being,
I'm being dramatic.
You're very successful.
I've been to your home,
the two.
Well,
and we give out the address.
Can I do that?
No,
he's very wealthy,
man.
Some bullshit artist trying to say he's not successful.
There's a bunch of,
look,
if you make more than $35,000 you're in the 1% of the world probably,
right?
No,
it is right be correct.
That is 100% like this combination.
Spinning elbow,
right hook,
left hook,
right uppercut and over the top.
Pop that jab in.
Oh for sure it needs it.
Oh yeah,
merged.
He immersed tonight is the most exciting light heavyweight in the world.
Solo.
Then Daniel and John.
I can't wait for that to just fucking Jab uppercut Christ.
It's so bad for your brain.
This is bad.
I hate it.
I just see his brain rattling around that skull.
Amazing,
amazing.
Most finishes and UFC light heavyweight history.
Jimmy Manoa.
Where's he at?
Shogun seven Gustafson seven chuck [inaudible].
Jon Jones nine.
Wow.
That Jon Jones,
DC rematches cause to me it's so interesting because I didn't think DC looked at
great against rumble off as more of rumbled not showed up.
Kate.
I thought DC like probably the worst we've seen body wise was it?
I'm getting that itch.
Show these boys how to throw an upper cut the right way.
Oh you know what?
That was a great uppercuts.
Silly what?
That's silly.
But what are you doing here?
He said he be in the article too.
He goes,
once I'm retired,
I'm retired.
There's no chance.
Well I see he sees Gustafson beating Glover.
I don't even knock these guys out.
He might think you could just jump back in there.
Does that make sense?
How crazy is that?
I'm getting that itch.
So I get the itch every now and then.
I've never telling anyone,
but how can he say that?
Right when he just got done retiring after a world title fight.
You know why?
Because your business manager it goes uh yeah.
So you were talking about that shit.
Listen,
the rambling pay 35 and this is the mascot,
a feminine Harry costs.
And then check this out.
So the marijuana,
you're an l,
it's tough business,
saturated,
saturated taxes.
So here's your taxes.
Taxes are 48% so you're going to make about 40 grand a when you do the numbers,
man,
when you like,
people make this mistake all the time.
They go to buy a bunch of stuff and they didn't do the real hard numbers.
Start talking to them and it's like,
oh fuck yeah,
there's a lot of people didn't want to spend a lot of money.
Yeah,
well,
what's really fucked up by his Porsche?
Let's talk about that.
Yeah,
I'm just kidding.
I'm not that dumb.
Don't buy that old portion of Lincoln you're doing,
you're going to love it.
Do you see it has the brand new turbo rims on it?
It's ridiculous.
Brand new turbo rems.
You're hilarious.
Do you see this?
I've seen a lot of actors not do those numbers and been in their house and God,
you're on a series now with this house
is a,
you're nuts about 40 grand a month and your,
your show is going to go away and you're just an actor.
How crazy.
Then a few in the same thing over and over.
As you know,
as an actor you've had how many failures,
you know,
it's nothing because it's going to end cause this is the ones it's friend cause
cause in as an actor you go,
this is the job that's going to push me over the edge.
I'm now famous and I'm gonna go from job to job and it never happens.
And I see,
I've seen it too many times.
It happens.
There's some people.
Yeah we were you always good with money Joe.
You cause you always made money.
Business managers you have,
so I'm harping on your right way.
Um,
I'm pretty good at it.
Here's the thing,
I like cars but I don't spend like a lot of money on jewelry or stupid shit and
cars.
You could actually sell like pen on the car.
Yeah.
My cars are worse investments.
We,
yeah,
some of them are bad investments with like my Corvettes worth a lot of money.
Like those are like old cars you could sell,
they're worth money.
Buys made money though.
You always made more money than most people know more than you right now.
And most of us as actors and stuff,
you're always,
yeah,
I always do a bunch of different things.
That's one thing I don't like having a boss and I don't like having to count on
someone and I like when you have fuck you money,
if you don't say fuck you,
I think it's a fucking disgrace.
It's a disgrace to the fuck you money.
If you don't say fuck it,
you have to get there though.
Yeah,
you got to have lunch today.
Fuck you money.
You're making 70 grand a year.
No,
no,
no.
But once you get fuck you money,
you have to know what it is like you,
okay now you have the opportunity.
You were in a fuck you position.
So you gotta know when to say fuck you.
And when you're just saying fuck you because you have fuck you money.
That does happen to people too.
They get that fucking money and then they can't wait to say fuck you.
And they pull the trigger on fuck you too quick.
Oh,
that's not a good
waiting for the does.
And we know,
we know people,
we know because what happens is you've got $6 million in the bank,
but you start spending $1 million a year.
I've seen that plenty of times.
What'd you say?
Be a lot of guys get $6 million in the bank and they'll start spending $1
million a year.
And I've seen that.
So you get six years ago out like a gangster.
Yeah,
those six years or so fun though.
My,
my buddy,
my buddy was making a lot of money and he came and he looked like he'd seen a
ghost and he said,
my business manager just told me I have to make $900,000 a year just to break
even.
And I went,
what do you spam dances?
Yup.
And I go,
what are you spending money on?
He goes,
just stuff.
And I said,
what?
He goes,
I got two nannies,
I got three cars,
I got a big house,
but I don't know,
just stuff.
And he couldn't really figure out,
you know,
until his business manager went line for line and was like,
this is what you're spending.
But you know what happens too when you start making money,
you start hanging out with other people that are making money.
You know,
I was talking to this pro football player who was telling me that he was saying
that basically what happens is you're around all these other dudes and camp and
the dude shows up with a roles and this guy's got a Bentley in,
this guy's got a giant gold chain and,
and he goes,
you start spending money just to keep up with these people.
Well Kevin Hart has a funny bit about that,
where he's hanging out with Dwayne Wade and those guys and they were talking and
Kevin's like,
I'm making money and doing what?
It was like,
you should buy a boat.
He was like,
what the fuck?
Fuck God.
And then they were pulling,
they were a club and he and Kevin was let me get their check and Dwayne was
like,
let me get it.
He goes,
now let me get it,
man.
Let me get it.
And he looked at the bill and he was,
it was so expensive.
He had to bring it in the light to make sure he had the number right.
He was like,
what does it
hurt now though?
But if that's what you want to do,
like if he just want to concentrate on money,
I mean the real problem is that requires a mindset of it's own.
And a lot of the people that are just financial entrepreneurs and people that
are like obsessed with making money,
they're not also creative geniuses.
They're not also pursuing a career in PR in the arts.
They're not Jevity.
Yeah,
I mean it's just you gotta you gotta know like what you're,
you're getting into.
So if you're a guy that just gets wrapped up and hanging around with rich people
and keeping up with the Joneses,
and if you an Indian stocks,
if you're an athlete,
it could wind up fucking up your career because you get so wrapped up in that
stuff that it takes some focus away.
Tell what else happens.
You did it.
You,
you're married to a girl,
she's hanging out with their wives and now she wants to get that,
that $10,000 handbag.
She wants that.
Ben's,
she wants that.
And you don't want to make her feel like she's not.
So she's in that group.
School's in session.
Talk to us.
Speech.
Keith,
older men,
thugs.
Listen,
these bitches,
they get together and they start,
oh my God,
what'd you get those shoes?
I got them from this side of that person is so hard to get.
I know a place where you can get it baby.
It's only thirty thousand thirty thousand dollars.
Crazy.
Cause you know actually,
you know you broke.
Yup.
Yeah.
This,
that the wives spending the money thing that happens and it happens in the
craziest way.
Don't,
don't,
don't marry a chicken.
Had them in their signs.
There's signs early on.
We are a bitch.
Can Be the chicken.
What's the sign?
What's a good sign?
Oh man,
there's so many red flags.
Where do I start?
That's by the way,
maybe your favorite.
My favorite shirt from you guys.
We are bringing the leg.
So why
slowly where the term chicken had come from?
I just comes out with things because he had no chickens run around.
It's been around.
But where did it come from?
I uh,
I'm not sure I missed,
uh,
at the time I was dating some girl and she was a chicken head.
I'm thinking why don't I went damn here,
one thirsty chicken head.
And she was like,
what the fuck?
Just call me.
And then they on the podcast like chicken heads man.
Pat Chicken head.
Yeah,
I definitely make up chicken head.
What year is this?
That just graduate high school.
Wow.
Late nineties.
Chicken head.
That song.
And was that what they were talking about?
Girls and they're singing about chicken heads.
See I didn't hear about it until I was hanging out with you.
I mean you got my baby.
I heard it a couple of times,
but I had never like heard someone use it where I started Holloway and I started
using it.
Choose the description from projects.
Okay,
here we go.
So what does it say?
Wait,
hold on.
Go up,
go walk up.
Chicken
leg ain't got no him.
The back jelled up.
Weaved up.
You'll hear they ain't got no hair and back.
Your hair is messed up.
Need to get,
get bout a hustle mission.
Get up on that boot run to get up on Lulu.
Ronna tissue.
Titian run game until the game is gravy.
That don't mean spend cheese.
Father the baby in a mock run game until the game is gravy.
That don't mean sped cheese for the baby.
Don't spend money on your baby.
No,
no,
no.
You need to get your hair in order for just to face right before you worry about
the nutritional requirements of your child.
You must now worry about pretty walk.
Walk head on a stock stock for a bootleg.
Got some cold water walk pretty walk.
Walk given out head ain't a thing.
Eat a chicken.
Wang got some gold teeth on the hey Siri,
this chicken chicken.
Always know some dumps.
It should have paid your light bill,
but you bought an outfit.
Stay at your Mommy's house.
Keep your smart mouth.
Oh my God.
Okay,
so it's just a derogatory term for a young lady.
A young lady who's just doing stupid shit that their lights are off,
but then they just got their nails done.
Chicken heads,
man.
Very interesting thing.
Did you see that Kale?
That dude got caught on the way down with a neat,
I mean it's like he slipped.
Oh hell
yeah.
He went for a knee bar.
He dove for a knee bar and got kneed in the head down.
Hey,
we're all fucked up.
Fucked up.
Really fucked Diego Sanchez.
They toss them to the wolves.
But yeah,
he tried to do that in minority spin that in minority dive hit him right in the
face.
Chicken head is maybe my favorite expression for a girl.
It's not you.
They don't call you like a piece of shit for doing it yet.
I don't think the feminists haven't caught on chicken head yet.
No.
That's why it's still cool right now.
The feminists don't like chicken heads anyway and there are that.
That's a phenomenon that exists.
Rising nationals on team vagina before anybody else.
Chicken head gets more popular.
We're all screwed.
Like there's a lot of people that are saying,
you shouldn't say bitch anymore.
I got stuff to do and I'll come on bitch a bitch.
Get outta here.
Fuck out of here.
It means too many different.
Try to take my language away from it not to.
I went saw wonder woman.
I was like,
I can't wait to this chicken had to work.
They don't give a fuck.
They don't know.
You know?
No,
they don't know.
You can still get away with this chicken and throw it down.
What is this thought thought?
No,
sure.
You guys called girls in schools that send out nudes and porn of themselves and
acra them to that hoe over there.
Can you hot and this like a spelling bee for the hood.
That's what I can I can I,
can you use it in the description man,
if you bang her but a rapid good that thought has given herpes and half the
school.
I'm not going with that one.
That's not going to last.
No,
I don't like it or off for a few years around for a while though.
It's not techy enough chicken.
That's hilarious.
If you use that,
you're probably annoying.
Yeah.
Thought column a thought that Hoe over there.
How about just say that hole over there?
Sure.
So stop like making girls feel bad about being sluts.
Yeah.
Why you slut shaming?
Yes.
Celebrate.
Fucking keep.
I have celebrated so we have more of it.
Yeah.
It was called the chicken coop.
Don't you appreciate road head?
Yeah.
It's on us to do it.
You stupid bitch.
It takes a certain mentality.
It's suck your Dick while you driving an automobile.
Correct.
Those girls are important.
This is just every girl.
You know what?
I'm just going to sign off.
You haven't yet.
This is over.
This fucking,
you're done.
You're dead to me.
Brian Cowen.
I always thought you were sophisticated.
I listen to your podcast on your own.
You read a lot of books.
No,
he's intrigued me,
but I know you're a piece of shit like you're fucking meathead friends.
You do get chicken.
I get scolded for not correct in the conversation.
Sometimes I thought more of you.
I'm like,
oh Jesus Christ.
There's nothing.
It's just got to,
no,
no.
Not Listens
to social media and this is a time,
excuse me.
I do not read my social media once in a blue moon.
I will did.
You would have made some corrections
on that case.
Hey,
what is this?
This A,
is this a,
is this a candidate would get me high.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure it'd be,
don't touch that.
Don't touch that.
You might get high.
Just looking at some joy.
Dia Shit.
Yeah.
Tim and I got a barbecue.
I'm hungry.
Family Barbecue.
I told you I'm the grill master.
You say you are,
but you're using less time.
Fucking grill off some cripple you.
Oh my God.
I have a real hard time with it.
I can't grill Zebra fucking wild boar and shit.
Same ribs on you.
I killed things.
You don't have a big brown Cheddar cheeseburger.
Oh,
I got,
I got a lot of burgers that I do.
I do elk with blue cheese,
so suck my dog and I do little elk had my chicken sauce also mixing pork fat
with my helper.
Her stop it.
Like you said,
you might want to just shut the fuck up.
I slice up Jalapenos easy.
That shit on Instagram,
I can slice up Jalapenos and garlic in the hill.
Never eat and my
pork fat.
Fuck you.
No,
I'm talking about traditional American cheeseburger.
I will see anyone powerful.
You go,
what's with breaking down the hot dogs?
Only in boiling water.
Well it depends on the petition.
All American cheeseburger,
cheeseburger,
cheeseburger.
Fuck you and your cheeseburger.
You even saute onions bro.
Are you fucking with me?
Saw you were,
had a sauteed mushrooms.
Do you grill peppers?
Bet your sweet ass.
Do you just saying stuff right now bro?
Dude,
I don't have to do it when you're thinking about no peppers,
but you don't really have a guy.
But if I can grill it,
the peppers,
I could tell he was fucking line cause he started grabbing his own beer and it
was called.
Yeah I do
because there was a tiny pause.
He went,
I sure do.
This is the move.
The move is we have Tom Papa Cook bread cause he gave me a fucking loaf of sour
dough bread.
Here's the media of the day.
But he baked it in the morning and I cheated on it that night.
I had,
I had bread and butter on it.
Nope,
just butter.
It was outstanding.
I said at some of it just raw,
just butter the bread for me,
but keep going.
He's very into it,
but it's because he makes it all himself.
When I get off from scratch,
it's so good.
Oh,
so this is the,
this is the idea.
We'll make some elk burgers with blue cheese in the middle.
Pork fat little together as one and then I flatten out.
I put blue cheese in the stature that fold that bitch.
Fuck you and your catch and keep calling fucking American.
What do you mean they'll catch out with blue cheese,
bro?
I grew up,
I grilled on grilled that bitch and we're going to put it in between two pieces
of Tom propers.
I'm hungry right now so bad.
My stomach is all cut up,
shredding fucking hands and Jalapenos on that motherfucker.
Of course,
a little bit of lettuce.
He wants him left.
Hey,
let's have Tom Papa make some nice fucking French toast and shut his fucking
mouth.
French toast would be,
we got fucked on posts it.
What happens now?
You just make the French toast.
I thought that's it.
He said,
no.
I said,
no,
I know that Parker doesn't fucking delicious.
I'm talking about straight up American grilled burgers like beef Burger,
beef burger.
I'm going from buffalo too,
but if you want to go buffalo hunting,
I'm going this winter,
I will,
and John Dudley,
we're going buffalo hunting.
Let's do it.
Can I have a gun?
You can.
If you're going to kill it with a boomerang
buffalo at that dangerous,
what?
What?
What's,
they'll charge your base.
One of the most dangerous things you could ever hunt it probably more dangerous
than a bear or they really low 1800 pounds of swinging dick and I've been around
them.
Mellow Bison.
I'll come at you bro.
Fucking bison.
They come out with a cam.
Haynes just got done a hunting water buffalo,
Australia there.
They're black dots.
Those are giant and here's the thing,
their meat,
you can eat it,
but it takes so long to chew because they're just checked.
The [inaudible] steel,
you eat the like the back strap,
which he told us,
he said,
when was this thing where this guy got charged by a bear?
I saw the video and he had a bow and arrow.
I post on Instagram.
Guys straight up panicked.
What?
The beer just left them alone.
Just jacked him,
knocked him over,
running the mode and they're just wants them to leave them the fuck alone.
The bear didn't want to eat like a shade up native American.
It wasn't.
Well he was using a recurve bow.
It's just he fucked up.
He got charged quick busted lip or herpes go.
Oh,
busted lip.
A bus,
lipid.
Herbie.
I'd
say it's herpes,
but who cares?
Listen man,
I'm going to say it's a busted lip.
Rather look like this.
However things get weird in there.
I guess that's a very round busted lip.
That's a brown perfectly symmetrical round hurt
like a motherfucker.
It's all good.
I get those sometimes.
Do you remember when,
um,
chocolate Liddell fought rich Franklin and his lip got split?
Yes.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
Powerful.
Retrained.
Yeah.
It was a crazy,
crazy split lip.
So Franklin just sort of stepped away.
He never really officially retired.
He just stepped back.
It was just like,
you know,
I'm a chill for a little bit split.
But then it wasn't like a big announcement,
like guys weren't doing it like they are now.
Then you went to warn us.
See.
Right.
It might be hard,
but let's see.
That looks like a herpes.
Me.
You might be right.
It's all good.
He's a married man.
That's,
that's all good.
That's a big strong,
it's stress.
Could be an elbow though.
Fuck around with chicken head.
Who knows?
Sure.
What about the gravy gravy?
Still a hero.
Herpes or no,
here.
A bad mother fucker.
Gustafson's bad motherfucker.
He emerged as one of the most exciting guys in the division right there.
He's motivated now.
Yeah,
man.
Especially with a wife and kid.
Yeah.
What's her name is standing on an apple box right now,
I guarantee you.
She is.
Yeah.
She's tiny and he's giant.
Um,
this,
uh,
those,
there's a lot of good fights to be made.
Madden's a lot of good fights to be made and a lot of guys are going to transit
UFC training.
They probably not one person there.
You.
Dot.
Yeah.
I don't think they didn't want me in jail.
They'll let you in.
I don't know.
How do they feel about what they tweeted me the other day,
so I'm like,
you know,
we might be cool some social media kit.
It's probably fired now.
They're probably flogged them around.
He's dead.
He probably went missing.
He hit him with a wet belt.
Slack right across the ass.
Take your water.
They probably waterboarded on or some shit.
He probably just didn't know this.
Brennan Sharp retweet.
Here's the problem.
As your celebrity grows and as the fighter and the kid continues to grow,
it is going to emerge if it hasn't already gotten there as one of the biggest
sports shows the world has ever known.
I mean you guys have millions of downloads.
When you look at the amount of downloads you guys have and you look at the
influence that you guys have and how many people listen,
like they'd be crazy to not jump on board with you.
Yeah,
I mean the big brown breakdown,
which is an all fight show is there.
I mean bigger than any show there as far as I'm,
it may not,
not the fight can pain,
but as far as straight up fight shows,
sports shows,
it's the biggest one that his last fight companion we did got 10 million
downloads.
God,
when we talk to you about fucking flat earth and talking in that one,
wasn't it?
That one.
What was the flatter with one is the one where you kind of got him daddy.
It might've been that.
I found that actually very interesting what people think I like some issue with,
I have zero issue with Yossi.
I'm over him.
I mean,
yeah,
I think there are over too.
I love the UFC.
I'm doing a one fight deal with Belotero for this big mask.
Where,
what,
what?
Why does it a little teeny Jake
for a financial New York?
What are you doing on business?
Have you made this announcement?
I am now that square garden breakdowns on there it is.
Wow.
I'm at a June 22nd Gotham Comedy Club in New York for the big round breakdown
live.
Right,
and then on the 24th 25th I'm working for spike doing TV stuff for the shit.
Just a one fight deal.
Listen man.
What spike is doing right now with having world class talent in Beltour
kickboxing,
worldclass kickboxer some of the best world,
Giorgio Petrosyan,
John Wayne par.
I mean some of the best fucking kickbox is in the world are fighting on Bella
door.
Then you sign it.
Rory Macdonald,
Lorens Larkin fade or big country now,
big country.
I mean they already have Douglas Lema,
you know,
they already have Michael Chandler.
They've got some serious fucking talent.
They just a real opportunity for them to take,
take that market share.
They got to get rid of that lame name.
Peloton Peloton.
I don't know why they keep get rid of that.
Right.
What would they call it?
Just spike MMA,
but they're not going to be spike anymore.
It's going to be something new.
I think 2018 they change.
I think spike TV is changing its name.
Just changed the name.
Yeah.
I think it's like the paramount station or something.
What is the ultimate,
what do they,
let's find out what they're calling it.
They're,
I think they're gonna change.
I think they're,
I think they are literally changing the name is that is paramount in that we're
here,
mount fight low.
I got my foam on the Pauls.
Hollywood shows.
Very few people that are in Hollywood that know less about Hollywood than me.
Yes.
But you knew that.
I knew that we bring in a hot new,
that paramount fight leaks.
Pretty cool.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
fire me,
give some kind of,
it's just MMA.
Just call it MMA.
Just like when you go to see boxing,
you're not seeing like,
you know,
fucking,
but you're going to have a mic.
Showtime,
Hbo.
Right,
right.
But it's HBO boxing.
Showtime fight night are paramount.
Fight night,
paramount Nmai hape review two or whatever.
Yeah.
And MMA has enough of a name now that I think you can like everyone knows UFC is
always going to be like NFL,
like NBA.
It's going to plead find.
It defines Q tips.
Right,
but I'll tell you what I do like with the UFC is doing.
I don't like that it's on fight pass.
I think that's a terrible idea.
But the data lights contender series every Thursday night there's like five
fights of luck.
Upcoming guys to build up new guys.
Yeah.
What's on fight pass?
We're only the balls.
Deep hardcore fans see it.
That should be on Fox sports one,
they need content like a motherfucker.
I came on Fox sport,
the pregame,
they had Bisbing and Gilbert Melendez guessing the capitals of Europe for 30
minutes.
That's important.
Not to freak the fuck guessing the capitals of Europe.
The fuck it was.
God.
This is the thing about live sports.
This the only thing that makes TV valuable these days.
The only thing if you take away live sports,
nobody's watching sitcoms anymore.
The numbers have dropped radically.
Nobody's,
I mean there's,
there's a few people watching those cop dramas,
those CSI shows is this people,
it was brain dead.
People in the Midwest is sitting in front of the TV.
Rhonda,
that's the bad guy.
Cause you get a car.
I was going to get caught.
That's a terrible character.
How could that character,
this is my shower,
this is my show.
Csi My show,
some
soda water drinking Dr Pepper Chips and shit.
But I think that um,
those shows are dropping off.
Like if you look at like Hbo,
the shows that they put together,
the show is showtime puts together the shows Netflix put together.
They're just superior thought and not interrupted by commercial,
especially the episodes and all that.
Yeah.
So the big thing for television is live sports.
Like a fight.
Like we came here to watch television.
We came here to watch a live fighting event.
I mean,
the live sporting events are like,
in my opinion,
the premier thing on television now.
It's really the only reason why you'd have cable,
to be honest.
For a lot of kids,
everything else you can get.
Jamie's generation.
These youngsters,
they're all abandoning their cable.
They're all turning off their direct TV and just watching their computers.
Yeah,
they're just getting at Netflix.
Well,
youtube red now has its own,
its own,
you know they have the TV shows on there.
They're getting movies.
Yeah.
They're going to be able to air television shows that are on television right
now on youtube.
My TV,
I got a TV at home and it plays Netflix from the TV without an apple TV with it.
Right.
Comes with Netflix.
It's in there.
So literally all you need to do now if you're a kid.
Yeah.
You have an internet connection.
You have a TV.
What do you watch TV wise on that house of cards.
I got to watch that.
It's good.
She's so good.
The new season starts at the end of this month.
I saw a Robin Wright and person at the one on one woman from air.
She's probably like 49 I don't know how old she is.
80 she looks so unbelievable.
It's so fucking good.
Would you do it?
Yeah,
100% 100% and you can give everybody at events and lose friends on the way.
Do you think you'd have a chance if she saw your act or do you think you'd have
to go back to acting?
Uh,
if she's on my act that Alex had a chance,
I'm discerning this room.
Yeah,
but do you think she would be caught dead with a comedian while she'd have to
come to my show?
I don't know.
Ninth and 10th Brow.
Maybe she will.
What if she shows up and sits in the front right where she fucked you up?
[inaudible] fuck you up to my boss at first,
if she kept crossing and uncrossing their legs and she was wearing one of those
clear Underwood skirts,
I have a problem.
She has a beautiful warm be.
She was Jenny and Forrest Gump.
Oh,
that's right.
I um,
sometimes I'll have like Nate Diaz came to my show in San Diego and I was Kinda,
I was cramped about that.
Yeah.
She look at her.
She's,
she looks so good.
He's well taken care of.
She's beautiful.
Wow.
Yeah,
she's cute.
She is.
She from.
I knew her for,
she was in princess bride first.
Too Young for that shit.
No,
there's something else.
I thought she was genuine.
Forrest Gump.
Jenny.
She was out fucking cut in that movie,
Dude.
She,
she,
she dictates that entire fucking movie.
And then finally she gets aids.
Let's do it for she supposed to do.
She supposed to hang around with this fucking half a mongoloid fuck
trip.
Oh,
he's fucking real good at ping pong.
No,
fuck you let them into my pussy.
Real guest limping.
You fuck works.
He's an Olympian.
Jesus.
She saw saying use the c word.
He's a fucking my girl now she's up.
She was a horn.
That movie.
Hey,
I will fight you right now.
The guitar naked and then just cocked my boy for and you to take this shit back
right now.
You Jenny.
I will come at you in this room
right now.
Is that a return now?
God,
she's incredible.
Hold like 50 yes.
So everybody shut up.
Hey be she's single issue that and I'm hearing no two kids.
Ben Foster.
Fuck Ben.
Ben beat him up.
I'll put him in a pop up.
I'll put my chin in his fucking eyeball.
Yeah.
Will you do that?
Hey Sydney,
Australia.
I swear I just saw season.
Great actor.
He's a great actor.
Ben Foster.
But I'll put my chin and he's fucking brilliant.
Yup.
What is he in hell or high water alpha dog until I put my chin.
That dude's a bad mother fucker.
You know what he was in?
He was in 30 days of night.
Yo,
you was crazy as it is.
A great,
great actor.
Fucking fun movie.
That was one of my favorite vampire movies be to that movie scared me.
That scared the shit out of here.
That's the scariest vampires are good vampires.
That movie was so good.
Josh Hartnett in that various Ryan.
That's a handsome kid.
Where's that fell Ben.
I don't know.
I saw him,
I saw him in Utah with his,
with his beautiful woman.
And why you phone?
I Dunno.
Poems in Montana.
Very nice guy.
I had a little small talk with them.
Anti ice cream shot interests a 10 I was like,
you need to just give me cause I do and I did too.
And he goes,
but you look like in such good shape.
I go,
I know.
Yeah.
He was like,
I love your word.
Sex in the city is your standup.
It's amazing.
Fuck Cujo whatever.
Fucking low blow,
Bro.
Why is it a little brown?
It's a good question.
What's your question?
I think that's a bad women.
Women,
women ask me,
what's wrong with you in sex in the city?
That was a big deal.
I was just a long time ago and now I'm insecure,
Bro.
I told you,
I don't know why guys,
if I don't get home and start firing up this grill.
All right,
let's take it over.
You got to press a button so I ain't even a real grip.
Meanwhile,
I use a pellet grill
but pellet grill because Pella,
you cook with wood.
It's,
it's actual,
what's 2017 there they are.
The gates on 2017
what gets into the military drills to the best.
They cook with smoke.
You smell the burning,
like miss smoky.
Yeah.
I like that shit about these pellet grills.
I know shit about cheese.
It's all about the cheese.
You have to sharp English,
cheddar cheese,
cheddar cheese from England or way over your head.
No,
no,
no.
When it comes to like smoking exotic meat and shit.
Fuck.
I'm reverse sear in food.
I'm cooking slow at two 75 with a meat thermometer.
Breach you motherfucker.
It's about the meet,
sir.
I'm all about Cherry Wood.
I'm using a lot of chairs.
How about you?
Oh,
I get it.
You're going to be cooking shows in like some OPEC Shit.
Don't make no food.
I'm not going to say skin.
When it comes down to traditional American hotdogs,
cheeseburgers.
See me,
bro.
Come at me.
And you're supporting terrorism.
Way to go.
Your food smells like it's cooked by your exhaust pipe.
Your fucking Bentley.
Yeah.
So it tastes like using gas,
Bro,
and keeping us gas dependent.
Hey Joe.
Thanks for using Cherry Wood.
Yeah,
I'm on your side.
You're not eating.
You're fucking your approach shot,
Bro.
You don't even know.
I like Trump did.
Yeah,
for real.
No,
don't do it.
They'll come at you like,
look what happened.
Kanye.
He went into a mental hospital,
they take go crazy.
Went pro Trump and they put them right in the fucking loony bin.
I like,
I liked what he said with the terrorists in Manchester when they asked him,
cause you don't expect the president.
It says cause they're losers,
they're losers.
These are more on losers.
I was like,
well
I would like more eloquent statement would you though?
Because like no one wants to talk about,
you know everyone the extremist don't only give them a name,
he just goes to their fight.
They're losers fucking losers because it like it is.
Cause if I see that,
that I got Dale you loser.
Fuck man.
No,
no.
Remember where the extremist now,
now you're loser.
Hmm.
I like that.
Anyways,
I'm going to go get this fucking grill started.
You focus on Shay would.
Okay.
This has been another fight.
This is so much fun and we didn't do nothing.
Got Crazy.
We didn't go off the rails.
Sometimes it's just good time though.
Sometimes crazy.
It's fun.
Maybe Jude turn.
Boy,
you crazy down for 10 sorry.
Maybe we'll get crazy far.
All Ready?
Ready?
Here's this Holloway.
All right,
everybody.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
We're sorry we didn't focus too much on the fights,
but hey,
we talked some about,
you know,
what you're getting when you sign up for the shale in New Zealand,
Hala [inaudible] k.
Dot com.
Hmm.